[Music]
on the right
and do it right cause we coming at you
locked back with the team had to keep it
OG must see TV yes we did cause we back
at it again
back at it again
foreign
[Music]
we've got none other than the lyricing
we've been fans of lyricing for a long
time controversial blah blah blah we
just loved you right away and we were
like this guy is a classic example of
the American dream who is like oh yeah a
lot of noise on the internet watch this
[ __ ] is it I don't think you're
controversial are you well just is it
he's caveman he's carnivore [ __ ]
vegetables all that stuff and so you're
gonna get a lot of we always say if
you're in the middle nobody knows if
you're if you're gonna get a lot of heat
but also a lot of admirers you're doing
something if you just stand for
something well here's the thing I don't
know how it could be controversial yeah
I don't know how there could really be
critics my message is not something I
invented right this is the message of
our ancestors this is the message of
your ancestors right this is how we've
lived for millions of years to express
our strongest healthiest most robust
version of ourselves right right so like
you want to hate or be a Critic of the
message that I'm bringing right I want
to say just how grateful I am that you
guys are having me on my course we've
been wanting you on for a while man and
I actually really know
opportunity yeah um here's the thing I
really need evolutionary Hunters primals
like you guys that have have you know
created amazing platforms like this
because um this is the only way I could
really spread the message and and I like
to start every podcast off just by
saying what I'm about to say just the
next 50 seconds I want to tell you how
grateful I am and what that really means
all right because you hear it all the
time we'll try not to interrupt well
this is what happens all the time hey
thanks for coming on oh yeah thanks for
having me I don't buy it I don't [ __ ]
believe it right right so this is what I
really mean by that right there's so
many [ __ ] people that are hurting and
hating their lives they're suffering
they're struggling there's such a
massive group of men today aimlessly
wondering about life they're submissive
they're weak there's no purpose no
passion no fight no unite they don't
know what to do but they know that
they're meant for more right we have
such a massive record of people that are
suffering with depression anxiety
infertility autoimmune low energy low
libido low ambition in life there's a
better life to live you guys know this
yeah you guys know this there's this
life to live of Adventure of excitement
of Love likes and laughter and so this
is the message that I'm championing I
dig it man and a lot of people a lot of
it's free three right well here's the
thing uh you can start doing this entire
[ __ ] thing today it will change your
life tomorrow I would say all of it's
free and if we're even talking about
food You're Gonna Save money I mean I
made breakfast this morning I had raw
eggs and it took I mean My wife brought
our eggs from our farm from Texas damn
she brought it here takes raw to raw
eggs boom and it's like you save money
most of stuff you save money and you
save time so I would say like it cost
little to nothing to do this and the
opportunity cost of living this other
subprime of Life a sub-optimal life
you're gonna pay exponentially more
living that kind of life that kind of
hurt that kind of suffer so again when I
say thank you that's exactly yeah but we
just got I I think Brennan and I just
loved your sense of humor about yourself
about the about the whole [ __ ] that's
a good message but there's also some
humor in it like you don't take yourself
too serious you know some of those guys
that are in the similar space like God
chill out oh I love it dude any time
somebody's talking about me I don't
[ __ ] care what light it said I'm like
do you realize how obscure I was
yesterday yesterday nobody [ __ ] knew
my name yeah and today you want to make
fun of me you want to do whatever you
want like I bring it all on there's this
guy who uh who doesn't have a massive
following but he said I will pay my own
way to liver King Ranch and if he
actually sleeps on wood if he actually
eats all the organs if he actually lives
the way he says he lives I'll take away
all my other videos and I'm thinking why
the [ __ ] would I want you to delete all
your other videos on me yeah again
you've introduced and here's the thing
at the end of the day what I speak is
truth yeah and and I don't care how they
come into my ecosystem you're gonna
interact you're going to connect and and
I think half the fun is ancestral tenant
tennis house I think what's weird too is
you were successful before this so it's
not like you have to do this for money
or for the life that you have you
decided to go from Rich and kind of you
know under the radar to choose this life
I say this all the time which I would
rather be rich and nobody knows who I am
I feel like that's the gig it was the
game yeah it's not actually and I'll
tell you why um I say this all the time
before social media a year ago I was
rich and Anonymous it's a pretty cool
Life to Live it's pretty cool dude um
and now I'm still Rich I'm no longer
Anonymous but not big Anonymous means
that my fight why we unite the message
that I'm expressing in the world people
recognize that right I'm creating a
difference like this is what I exist for
today yeah what I do in my personal
professional life is in harmony so this
is why I would say now I'm okay paying
that price that sacrifice because we're
all connected right if you think that
you're going to go wish harm upon your
enemy like there's such thing as
competition well people want to catch
you what I never understood is that so
there's this food's emotional food's
religious I mean but people who are
vegans are just as religious as anybody
else people who are carnivore are
religious about their carnivore there is
this idea that I I am trying to hack
what's best for my longevity and my
health and people get very passionate
about that and so what I think cracks me
up is that they'll take a guy like you
who's living this life and they go I bet
you I bet you we can catch them sleeping
on a [ __ ] bed yeah liar it's like
that's not the point you [ __ ] exactly I
don't give a [ __ ] yes maybe he sleeps on
uh Four Seasons bed sometimes not the
[ __ ] point that's the crab mentality
like that's what you realize once you
reach some level of Fame you're like oh
these some people suck because it's
triggering like your success is
triggering yeah are you spreading this
word which is a positive message it's
triggering to them it's also free you're
also free you're also doing whatever the
[ __ ] you want not wearing but the price
of the price of Fame can like for your
wife do you tell you're gonna do this
and your kids we're like Dad come on man
we can't go anywhere now they're paying
the price too
or my kids couldn't breathe when they
were younger they were going to the
hospital because they couldn't breathe
they needed anaphylactic they were not
an anaphylactic shock they needed an
EpiPen um they know what why we're doing
this and so when we talk about so we we
just um started a a TV show and um it's
gonna be really exciting but um this is
going to launch the message so much
further you know than it is right now do
we really want to do this like we
wouldn't say oh yeah let's go do this
like for the sake of being famous yeah
it's doing it because our why in the
world is my kids couldn't breathe their
life was horrific imagine what and when
we started Living this way the light
bulb came on now they could breathe they
no longer went to anaphylactic shock but
the light bulb their personalities came
to life it was the food that was causing
it the nutrition it was us it was what
we were again we take full
responsibility for it it's the food that
we were giving them and it's it's the
lack of the other ancestral tenants we
weren't really we were putting sunscreen
on them you know we weren't really
getting them out in the sun we lived in
the in the in the city and their bare
feet were never really anchored or
connected directly to the Earth sleep
Sun cold you talk about cold being a big
thing these are thermal pressures right
I do say cold but they're thermal
pressures we evolved with thermal
pressures since the very [ __ ]
beginning right Comfort is not good for
the organism it's only through struggle
active suffering active struggling this
kind of resistance this is what we do in
the gym we create resistance so that we
can create an adaptation right so that
we can become stronger yeah so one of
the things that the the as they were
settling the west and they came into
contact with Native Americans one of the
things that blew the minds off the
Europeans the the hunters the Trappers
the the Cowboys was how the like the
Apache the Comanche the Sioux how they
would be it'd be [ __ ] literally 10
below zero and they would have parts of
their skin exposed yeah their their
tolerance for cold was otherworldly they
just could yeah and no foot covering
either yeah they just literally they
would write about this they were like
how the [ __ ] are these is this cheap
sitting here on this horse not cold or
not bothered by this and you know the
Europeans would be and they were pretty
hearty people they're just not used to
it yeah well they used to give your
Barefoot right now and when I'm in the
modern world and I'm walking on 160
degree [ __ ] asphalt broken [ __ ]
glass I'm putting these things on my
feet yeah right ancestrality I wear
shoes my man I get the message in L.A
you're going to step on it that's right
syringe yeah right what'd you say on a
Serenity don't walk down Venice Beach
Barefoot yeah that's danger yeah you get
monkey but you got Shields good way to
get monkey balls Shield is part of it
right yeah so it's sleep eat move Shield
connect cold Sun fight and bond that's
all nine of these right and a lot of
them were born out of first principle
thinking but all of out of medical
necessity for my kids and then I really
wanted to know like do our early
ancestors did they really live this way
and what's the best way we can really
figure this out so we started visiting
with primitive culture tribes modern day
primary culture tribes around the world
we've been to the Amazon we've been to
Africa we're headed to Mongolia next
we've got to trip
there we go
because we didn't tell them you're
coming on and yesterday I was like oh
yeah big day because I have the fighter
bow nickel coming on after this I was
like we got a big day man we got liver
King and Bone nickel and he's like what
the you didn't tell me I was like yeah I
don't want to get too excited mark would
go lift and just get ready for it I love
it I feel the connection outside yeah
I've been up since 3am like because like
uh uh yeah you wake up
yay he said a liver King he goes you
smell good dude you're so good I expect
you not to smell good what if we found
out you guys driving up the 3am I've
been jacking it so hard on our videos
yeah just a shrine and liver King in my
room
um but I was you know like when you have
that moment sometimes you're like oh I
could go back to sleep but the moment I
was like liver King's coming on today
it's like can't go to back to sleep now
well the thing about this right the the
chemistry and the culture you create in
here the electricity yeah can you do
this with your [ __ ] phone in front of
your face no and by the way is this your
phone right here oh yes it's like are
you feeling
people run social media tell them what
to post stuff like that but I'm not on
social media I'm not my I'm probably my
phone the least out of this room yeah
calendars Tick Tock dances and [ __ ] at
55. we'll talk about later
tell me about that because a lot of the
sort of they talk about EMF they talk
about phone stuff Wi-Fi I have never
read a conclusive study and I haven't
read any studies about the best dude 5G
should we start on 5G yeah I want to
know about that what is your what is
your honest thought about Oh you mean
the truth I mean I I believe blue light
and being on your phone is bad for you
just because you're you're it's probably
bad for your eyes and you're just on
your phone yeah you're not connected but
do you think there's a physical
education um
so here's what I'll say most people are
living a life today that they [ __ ]
hate they go to a job that they hate
they come home to a life they don't love
and they sedate themselves for the rest
of the day yeah with enough TV whiskey
or whatever the [ __ ] else it is
alcoholic and I'm wondering why didn't I
not get a cup of this by the way
not only did we do that with a messiah a
couple of times but we do that at liver
King Ranch now so we brought that
practice back to liver King Ranch and
how cool is this it's a renewable
resource people think you've got to
slaughter the animals you get the blood
this is milk and blood are renewable
resources the the Messiah figured this
out well the Mongols were impossible
what they would do is the Mongols would
lead you out into the desert now if
you're following the Mongols with your
army you have to bring water
the Mongols would tap they would drink
Mare's milk and they would drink uh at
the blood they would just tap a vein
while they're running yeah it'd be like
dangle come on out and all of a sudden
now you got to turn back around and your
whole family there's uh vampiring these
horses you guys are sucking on the
horses that's right liver Queen does it
the boys do it we all do it well you
guys look pretty healthy you're right
they're close to two boys online that's
why I love bringing her on to podcasts
too because once everyone starts acting
all subprime well they don't want to eat
the testicle or or the bone marrow it's
like my wife is gonna eat you under the
table get over here liver Queen yeah my
ego's not that's fine
not mine not mine I'm like but I'll do
it I'll deep throat whatever you do let
me answer this question because
um people are really suffering today
right and so it's all nine ancestral
tenants ancestral tenant uh Forest
Shield we have all these non-native
things around us today and and if you
think about it for the first time ever
we're we're never connected to the Earth
anymore right every cell in our body
thanks brother cheers guys yeah let's
let's do a legitimate cheers yeah I'm
gonna
yeah and then I want to hear this this
is cheers boys to the liver king living
your life to me
so here's the things is that every cell
in our body is electrophysical in nature
um and what cells do is they signal to
the next cell to say something to
organize to become tissue that tissue
organizes to become our organs our
organs organized to become who we are
and we no longer are connected to the
Earth which has a slightly negative
charge
and we're allowing all these emfs all
these non-native emfs to interface and
interrupt our sell signaling today every
cell has a voltage-gated calcium channel
in it and they can no longer behave that
they're the way that they're meant to
behave and so listen do you need your
cell phone you had thank God hey you had
yours here yeah yeah where did you have
yours this is on my dick and balls no no
no no but but I had a
race keep it people do keep it here and
that's their pocket listen
and so let's just say there's no
conclusive studies why not just use
first principle thinking in hedge listen
you want to have it hedge a little bit
yeah right do you do you need your phone
on when you're sleeping do you need your
Wi-Fi in your house when you're sleeping
right when you're sleeping this is the
most important point of your day the
most important part to restore to
recalibrate to reload for the next
[ __ ] day yeah put that [ __ ] in
airplane mode put that stuff on wi-fi
turn your electricity off if you can
pull your your bed away from the wall so
you don't have the power outlets right
next to your [ __ ] brain like we're
suffering today with the most horrific
neurological conditions so all I'm
saying is Shield is legitimate right and
you can look at this is not just with
with with cell phones and Wi-Fi it's
with the [ __ ] that we're wearing right
we're wearing polyester clothes
petrochemical clothing we're wearing
perfumes Plastics we're wearing the kind
of [ __ ] that these are all man-made
things we're always exposed to it and
we're also exposed to a cocktail I have
so much chemicals it's a Malu and it's
all compound there's so much to our
detriment now listen if you're over here
kicking ass in life you're expressing
your potential I don't even care what
you [ __ ] eat what you do go kick ass
in life okay if you're saying that I was
feeling bad about them
that is true like just following your
Primal urge doing what you're supposed
to do when you get to a point where you
know where to place your energy that's a
huge part of the battle and then the
rest is this the way I look at it is
that you love what you do you don't want
your body to be in the way so for me
health is about like what is how can I
eat and work out where my energy is
optimal where I don't calcify plus I'm
55. you've always been that way though
yeah yeah but but I was taking care of
himself always because I I just don't
want to get I don't want my body in the
way but I am grind and wake up looking
like a Sharpay well and I have to myself
five more weeks for my Invisalign and
then I'm gonna have beautiful teeth yeah
they're getting there we need to talk
about that Invisalign well that's all
[ __ ] I was going to ask you about
that don't don't get your [ __ ] pair
really my wife's a retired biological
dentist right and what do you mean a
biological dentist
like a function
no right why did you get in this line in
the first place first place because
my lower teeth were getting crazy right
so more people guys City skylines yes
and on camera it just looked [ __ ] you
did it for Aesthetics yes how much you
want to bet that your bite had had
finally figured out a functional bite
for you and and we're gonna take off
probably true
guess what congratulations now you got
an aesthetic smile but you [ __ ] up
your bike and now you're gonna be in a
sympathetic mode a more fight or flight
more anxious
listening
five more weeks bro I've been sitting
there like a good boy
I will when I'm gonna eat that [ __ ] yeah
you bet you will but wait we also had
his Lids done here did you ever study uh
did you ever study Western price uh
Western this is really the Catalyst that
changed our life it is well it was
nursing Traditions
educated he had a he had a hair
transplant and then he also had his eyes
done I had my eyes he said several
cosmetic surgeon yeah but I've always
warned him about it I've always told him
like dude you're not living your truth
shut up here we are now here we are now
and we can live our best [ __ ] lives
tomorrow right there's so many people
that say oh I'm 55 I'm 60. I'm [ __ ]
you know um this is funny there's a
bagpipe player um in the UK
who I was actually trying to pick a
fight with I thought oh this will make
great content it's gonna make I'm gonna
go pick a fight with this guy and say
hey man stop playing he's gonna say no
no I'm not I'm gonna say I'll just pay
you to get that hideous [ __ ] music
out of here so I show up and he go and
where's this ad that's in London
well oh I love him too but I I wanted I
wanted views yeah and uh and and as soon
as I showed up he goes oh my God it's
the liver King and stop playing oh but
yeah he stopped playing fact he's
falling on him but then then he followed
me around London playing on the battle
it was incredible and uh and this guy
said you know the best time to plant a
tree was 50 years ago the second best
time is today oh wow and and this guy
was so so wise yeah you know and that's
the thing and you want to fight him you
wanted to fight them eight yeah that's
right you know and this is what we're
fighting for this is what we're uniting
for I don't care what what age you are
if you're wearing Invisalign whatever
you're doing whatever you're about to
have you know these these nine ancestral
tenants the things you can do today it
will change your life tomorrow we're all
on this path to becoming better we're
all learning more every [ __ ] day
right so if you want to but you don't
like your business even if this line
you're against say again you're against
it the Native Americans
huh damn you wanna drink cowboy and do
all this [ __ ] in the winter you're a
bully do the Native Americans get their
Lids done Brian maybe let's take a
little break from Chow the liver King
himself dude yes let's take it because
we're meeting liver on tour now and I'm
eating all the liver in Boston tell me
the truth when you talk to him don't you
want to eat liver like I I don't want I
don't like liver but I'm gonna start I I
felt a little sick when I ate that liver
yeah but I'm gonna start I feel like you
get used to it can I cook it you can 100
Cook it'll be fine yes does anybody you
could got to be all right it's just the
raw meat even cooked liver sucks but if
it's that good I'm gonna do it yeah even
it goes down about 20 but I'm eating uh
raw liver in Boston I'm not sure what
kind of Boston liver they have up there
but give me your livers Boston you're
this weekend yeah this Thursday Friday
Saturday Boston laugh Boston all shows
almost sold out my at a show Saturday
then San Jose California October 13th
through the 15th Salt Lake City Wise
Guys shout out to Keith October 20th
through 22nd and then I end October in
Calgary Calgary Canada October 27th at
the Rooftop in Calgary Canada and we're
going to add a show on the 28th that
Friday in Calgary come get some
thickboy.com well I'm in Chicago bring
liver bring liver Tacoma Washington I'll
see you this weekend basically Seattle a
half hour outside of Seattle can't wait
September 28th I mean 29 30 uh October
one that's at the Tacoma comedy club
Bridgeport Connecticut Stress Factory
October 13 14 15 Schaumburg Illinois
Chicago improv what's the liver like in
Schaumburg we'll find out we'll find out
remember it's October 27th through 29th
and it's not in Chicago is it Brandon
it's about an hour outside
more an hour well if you're in traffic
Brennan it's Shaumburg but then I got
Charlotte which is getting hit by a
[ __ ] hurricane right now and then in
Naples also well we don't know if Naples
are going to be there in this Naples off
the hook December one you know you're
not allowed to fly into Florida right
now or leave our boy real flights now
our boy Eric will have I Naples is when
I think of I think of Regina that
restaurant and our boy Eric yeah me too
and uh hopefully he's okay yeah
hopefully he's okay dude do you remember
the last time you're at the gas station
be and you saw those horribly branded
erection pills yes I don't take Dino
5000 get your wiener oh thank you dude
you don't want that stuff it's not
healthy you've got a four-hour erection
nasty side effects heart problems all
kinds of things that's that's even in
the other stuff yeah and thank God for
our friends at Joy mode listen they're
here to save the day with your happier
unhappy with your performance in the
sack why not perform even better
pre-workout optimize your wiener dude
Joy mode sexual stuff is going to help
you out man Joy mode makes natural
science-backed sexual wellness products
for the Bros their sexual performance
boosters it's like a pre-workout but for
sex it's designed to support
erection quality and firmness and sex
drive contains clinically supported
doses of l-citrulline arginine yohimbe
and vitamin C created in world class
best the world-class scientists dude a
little liver with biochemistry do you
need a little liver and some Joy mode
and maybe some tests maybe some raw
testing maybe man and listen if you want
Spice up in the bedroom and boost your
sexual performance who doesn't want that
and do it naturally all right we got you
we have a special offer for you guys to
find the kid viewers and listeners go to
usejoymode.com fighter or enter fighter
at checkout for 20 off your first order
that's use
j-o-y-m-o-d-e.com slash Fighter for 25
for your first order thanks Joy mode let
us know what you think
yeah this so let's talk about Rhone for
a second dude I I they sent me some
stuff and you know we get a lot of stuff
it's but I got the wrong time dude the
the dress shirt and the pants I was like
I could get down that's really wrinkle
that's the thing well think about when
you you've worked in a in a bank before
and you have to wear a suit think how
comfortable is to wear a suit all day
I'll just set a few have to wear a suit
I'm like this is so uncomfortable I wish
I had grown on my body they got this
Segway they got this uh the commuter
shirt right it's comfortable breathable
flexible and it's got Mobility you're
not you know tied into this kind of like
hard starchy fabric it's also wrinkle
free dude that's what's crazy about it I
know that's gonna sit down all day and
they stand up in your normal dress
there's no way to take a dress shirt put
it in a if you travel the way I do you
know you better have an iron and even
then you better know how to iron I don't
know how to do 1987 it's got gold Fusion
anti-odor technology so you smell fresh
and clean all day long on top of that
it's 100 machine washable so you can
ditch the dry cleaner all together come
on you just feel good and then also
you're you're looking stylish at work
you're going to happy hour you're
meeting your friends or your lady for
dinner you still look fresh Mobility you
want Mobility I street fight I dance you
know the mobility and I like to have sex
with my shirt off sometimes or you don't
want to rent with your own shirt on you
don't want to wrinkle it that's exactly
right I look good while you're in the
sack a commuter shirt yes all their
clothing as somebody who owns it all
their clothing they're both Top Notch
their pants are great they're
comfortable they look dope head to Rhone
r h o n e.com slash fighter use the
promo code fighter you get 20 off the
entire order that's 20 off your entire
order when you use Roan r h o n e.com
slash fighter use code fighter it's time
to find your corn office comfort you
know we got this company it's called
strongja tell them all right our early
ancestors didn't brush didn't floss and
didn't get cavities you look at the
massage you've never seen such beautiful
teeth you've never seen they don't brush
their teeth they don't brush your teeth
their teeth are if yeah the Maasai bring
up the Masai chin if you look at them
outside I was there the first time I was
in the 70s I was telling you I went to
Kenya and Tanzania Masai
m-a-s-i-r-a-i so absolutely Florida
fluoride or anything because they're
diet fluoride's a joke also my fluoride
might Harden your tooth but it makes it
brittle doesn't resist the K now hold on
T the cavities went down we have to get
into this because you know the Maasai
yes they are good most indigenous
sculptures they're primarily carnivore
they they drink high fat milk from from
the animals drink blood eat meat but you
know a lot of these cult like the Dinka
the newer the tall cultures you know the
Dutch I think were primarily milk
Drinkers and meat eaters and wheat
eaters you know so it's true that
depending on the diet if you look at the
northern Europeans who tended to be
taller if you look at the Africans that
were but I don't know I mean in America
I'm sure it's the sugar it's the
processed foods which cause it's real
it's two main things that's so again
people think you brush your philosophies
oral hygiene hypothesis this is the
wrong Paradigm in the first place this
is why this is a tough message to to
Really Advance today right I'm listening
because your teeth are pretty good
because because we got to change this
Paradigm again people think oh we're
going to brush we're going to floss
guess what the the highest incidence of
brushing and flies flossing we have the
highest rates of character right and and
so here's the thing it's what we eat
it's how we nourish ourselves we need
predominantly the fat soluble vitamins a
d k e but it's how we mechanically load
so you look at the Messiah you look at
what they eat the [ __ ] that they're
eating you can't eat you I don't know if
you've tried their food no it'll take
you 30 minutes to eat what they've eaten
in two minutes is that right oh it's
like ask liver Queen I mean the kids
hated eating with them because their
jaws their jaws hurt so bad they're so
stronger what do you mean yeah because
um the way that they cook so that
they'll still roast the lamb you know
they'll put it over the fire for about
five seconds but it's so hard it's so
tough yeah you know but it's not just
the Messiah the matcha ganga and the
Amazon exact same thing you're there
chewing for 30 minutes man why they want
it so difficult
no it's not difficult it's not bread
it's not fat on corn they're tearing
through it right we're meant to
mechanically load when's the last time
you used your centrals your incisors
when's the last time you use these front
teeth to mechanically load what have you
ever broken your leg or arm and put it
in the cast no personally
because it's not mechanically loaded
this is what's happening to us today
right we like meat that falls off the
bone most people eat the equivalent of
baby food they don't mechanically load
their teeth you're right right and so we
got the biggest pandemic today people
have chronic and recurrent Decay and and
but this is just like a window and
insight to other issues my teeth hurt
right now your teeth hurt right it does
have problems I'm gonna stop brushing my
teeth like sugar after this I'm gonna
stop brushing my teeth sugar
carbohydrates those kinds of things that
break down that that is what causes
tooth decay right not necessarily uh so
so that does affect the parotid gland
um so what I would say we all have the
ability to resist Decay to rebuild or
enamel right but we got to stop eating
the processed food because that does
affect the product gland that that's it
creates the phosphorus the calcium the
things that re-mineralize our teeth but
we need these fat soluble vitamins start
eating liver bone marrow egg yolks get
sun that's what you need for proper or
to his point though like I've been on I
was on Carnivore for about six months
I've been on it now for about three
weeks my teeth do not hurt I remember
that you actually he actually because he
would eat sugar because he's got
problems with his teeth oh yeah
sweetness he acid and the sugar so he
stopped and he basically started doing
carnivore part of it but that when
people say oh so is it the sugar and the
carbohydrates you know that break down
that ferment that create this you know
the the byproduct of of fermentation is
that acidic environment that's part of
it yeah that's part of it but so it's
the nutrition that we take in and it's
mechanically loading the teeth so it's
not enough just to eat liver this is
going to get you probably 80 of the way
there you say 80. 80 of the way they're
pretty good eat liver bone marrow egg
yolks get sun okay that's probably gonna
take care of most of your oral it has to
be raw or it can be cooked don't let
perfect be the enemy of good just get it
get it get it any way you can
Roz the best I was the best why is we're
all the best enzymes well yeah there's a
whole lot of things that are DNA he
kills a lot of the nutrients and a lot
of the nutrients a lot of the peptides a
lot of the signaling the things that
other your body don't you feel like
Jeffrey Dahmer sometimes you're just
eating this raw meat all the time well
isn't he pretty [ __ ] Primal yes
yeah Brandon Jeffrey Dahmer's all bad
now
all right I mean
morality you can't say he wasn't a
[ __ ] man right you you take that out
he only [ __ ] other dudes Yeah Yeah
well yeah that's nothing wrong with that
I mean
but I am fascinated with the idea like I
know the Mongols you're going to
Mongolia you're going to go study the
eagle Hunters now I don't know if you
know this thank you the hunt Eagles sir
that's fine if I may if I may the golden
eagle the golden eagle and he's gonna
get into this no sir what you do is you
you send that out now there's video on
YouTube of them catching and killing I
don't think it's foxes I think it's
actually wolves I don't know if you've
seen this they catch other birds why
don't you bring that attaches well
they're from Mongolia it's the it's the
coldest part of the world changes Khan's
stomping grounds where these guys
learned how to tame these massive golden
eagles and they'll grab they'll go kill
a wolf for you well they have pet Eagles
uh yeah they're pet eagle yes sir
they're not bald eagles they're [ __ ]
the biggest golden eagles you're going
to do this that's right oh that's them
picking up the stress one they drop them
off they bring them to you no they drop
them Mongolia
the Mongols used to grab they used to
harvest like like field mice they'd so
they'd sow an entire like um coat out of
uh the mice holy [ __ ] look at the Town
look at this watch this what's his name
that's a wolf sir is that a wolf or a
fox I think it's a wolf that's a fox or
coyote maybe that's a tiny little
[ __ ] they're not picking up big walls
come on buddy
yeah
and so they're saying do this because
this just looks like they're doing this
on their own those are tiny uh well they
they will so there's a small tribe
there's this it's a custom that goes
back I think for a long time and they
will they will send the eagle out to
catch food that's pretty cool that's how
they hunt and that's where they headed
that's where we're headed that's been
cool yeah and they're primarily like
carnivore aren't they you know I don't
know here's the thing thank God of
choice we have a great a great team that
sets these things up and half the time I
have no [ __ ] idea what we're getting
into oh you get there that's best that's
awesome natural reaction yeah yeah yeah
and uh you were like well we'll see half
of what you're saying I'm like okay yeah
I didn't know any of this yeah
it I don't know if we're hunting eagles
or if the Eagles are hunting for us
thank you for ruining my [ __ ] sorry
surprise well the Mongols were the first
people just so you know they were really
the first people that were that because
horses are indigenous that part of the
Gobi desert they were the first peoples
to domesticate horses and so when they
would hunt they had they would do it on
Horseback and they would they would
Corner the deer either they'd run them
off cliffs or they'd Corner them and
spare them and shoot them with and they
were also I believe the first people to
invent stirrups so what does a stirrup
do when you're on a horse it allows you
to be more stable you pull back and you
can shoot from the horse that's why they
were such a nightmare to fight because
yeah they would they would do that to
armies they could the way they would
herd like the the deer and things like
they're out there in the Gobi desert
because there's nothing to grow you're
not growing [ __ ] out there you have to
catch everything it's basically your
your herder and you gotta hunt so what
they would do on their horses is they
were sick Horsemen there were all these
stories about them shooting a bird out
of the sky with their with their bow and
arrow that's why they were so [ __ ]
formidable and they lived basically on
this this the the Chinese would talk
about uh and the missionaries would talk
about how they would take this blood and
Mare's milk and they would ferment it
and create this like gelato this thing
that they would drink and they would be
delicious we mixed that as well at home
but here's the thing my you asked my
kids about this right about the trip
um because we're going from a six star
resort in Dubai to a zero Star City you
know no running water nothing is going
on you know what a great education for
your kids exactly you know because uh
homeschool is something that was just
invented this is brand new [ __ ] right I
mean from from the Inception of our Bing
we never outsourced eight to ten hours a
day of our kids going to learn values we
never did this thing right we brought
them along with us to hunt to build to
protect to fight to persevere to model
right and and so we recently started
Outsourcing this job and so I'm like
okay if I can take my kids to the Amazon
to Africa to New York to Las Vegas and I
really wish they were here today yeah
right because I always say what we do is
far more important than what we say I
want to show you guys how to do this
stuff that's how they get an education
it is and do they play sports and stuff
or no they're just they play sports um
here's the thing uh what they a they
went to private school when I was uh
Brian Johnson when I was my predecessor
and they were kicking ass in private
school and I don't know if you guys know
my story but long story short uh we we
we're in a financial crisis for about a
decade our home was being repossessed
our cars you [ __ ] what was your
business we owned an Imaging Center a
dental lab a dental practice it was a
pretty big operation and uh and one day
the the schools were hey your kids can't
come anymore you're this far behind oh
yeah you've said this before but one day
they were like no they really can't long
story short now we're going to public
school we we moved from our house had to
sell everything we live we rented a
house is this in Texas this is in Texas
wife and I are sharing a truck uh damn I
kind of want to share the story of how
we got the truck but I'm not going to
um here's what ends up happening is our
kids go to public school and we realize
they're not nearly as talented as what
we thought in private school yeah in
private school they were kicking ass in
public school and private schools yeah
right they would go to public school and
this one kid Brady throws a football to
Striker hits them right here in the
Bread Basket yeah knocks wind out of
them and he kind of tears up and says I
don't I'm not going to football practice
Yeah I'm not playing football practice
and of course I'm like sounds like his
private school was all white kids you
know what it was out there it was also
Primal white yeah all just all whites
it's just you're the fastest white
here's the real world and so so this is
the deal you know it's like this is the
real world I want them to learn this
real world [ __ ] so at that point I said
you know I don't give a [ __ ] if you guys
want to play sports or not I'm going to
make you guys into men you're gonna work
out twice a day you don't you don't want
to play sport you don't have to play
sport but you're gonna work out twice a
day we're gonna get you strong I'm gonna
get you prepared to play any [ __ ]
sport you want to play when it's time to
play sports so they've always worked out
twice a day they do Jiu Jitsu they do
striking they do ninja training and like
like I said they work out twice a day
six days a week so they're ready for the
uh ninja training what's that you mean
like parkour no no I mean it's uh you
know like with a sword and oh gotcha no
no it's like American Ninja Warriors oh
that's cool oh that's cool okay yeah
it's calisthenics American Ninja not
Ninja Japanese ninja not assassin [ __ ]
where you wear this throwing stars and
poison it's American yeah they're very
stinky they're actually here right now I
just don't know it they're so the walls
are so good at Georgia yeah
decided to take them this
I am this is very Bittersweet for me for
them to not be here today yeah you know
yeah you know because when I get to meet
you guys like yeah I'm like you guys are
Masters in your respective disciplines
and I always ask why why do you do what
you do how do you do what you do and I
want them to learn from this kind of
stuff like they have these opportunities
to connect with guys like you that's an
education for them yeah I agree man I
think it comes I think it comes down to
original self-expression that's one of
the things I like about you is that
you're just an original and you you came
along and you were like [ __ ] this I'm
gonna live the way people I'm actually
gonna live this Primal lifestyle well
remember I did it out of medical
necessity I didn't I just have like this
thought one day that was this original
expression like I did it because my kids
couldn't breathe and I'm done with all
these Solutions all these guys are
saying allergy shots Benadryl epipens
relegated to a life of babysitting
you're everywhere when you went like if
the kids went off on ski school you got
to give them all this stuff you got to
talk to them for 30 minutes and then you
gotta still like watch them at lunch and
did you go down that path and like there
has to be a better way oh we went down
that pathway because we have a similar
my kid uh he could breathe but he was
born when he was two they started uh
kind of coming to fruition he started
having really bad seizures and so we
took him to the doctor they said you
know he's two and I'm freaking the hell
out and having to connect all these
machines yeah he has these really bad
seizures when you have medication they
gives the the paper to go get him his
medication so my girl picks it up she
was giving this like big pill I'm like
let me look into it so I start looking
into it and I just stumble upon this
like Mom Forum yeah and all these other
moms their kids had the same seizures
it's like an eye seizure so it feels
like a sharp pain through their brain
and his lips would turn blue like all
through the night like two three how
that makes you feel when I wanted to die
I want to die I remember I literally I
literally wanted to die exactly so
you'll do anything to figure out dude
and then I you know I'm not like
anti-vaxx or anything like that but he
got all the vaccinations in California
they have to give him over 70 before the
age of two so the the vaccine actually
caused the seizures because all the
Mercury and all that stuff in the
vaccines and so uh he had those seizures
and they want to give him the medication
and but I go online like this I don't
know man and I see all the side effects
from it and then I just stumble because
I'm research on the internet at some
point remember what medication it was I
don't I stumble upon this uh like Mom
form yeah like this mom group chat and
they're like do not give your children
medication it Zone my kid out he's never
been the same his personality [ __ ] yeah
they sedate them for enough decades
correct like my son's never been the
same I wish I didn't do it and they're
like try CBD try CBD try natural CBD and
I'm like [ __ ] I'll try CBD I'd rather
try that and see if it works so I have a
buddy in Todd Feldman and he's been
swearing by CBD and this cup this family
makes it in Venice I know dude I need
CBD I go pick it up at one in the
morning drive back give to my son he
never had another seizure never and how
old is he now he's six so after four
years never had another nothing he's
gonna fine and you know it's wild people
don't talk about this stuff right um not
in the mainstream and and you know what
is in the mainstream which people still
don't really talk about there's
evidence-based ketogenic diets the
Charlie Foundation is related to this
the ketogenic diet is an evidence-based
therapy for seizures epilepsy and stuff
like that who talks about it yeah nobody
talks about my friend's uh son is that
does that he he uh a high fat diet uh a
ketogenic diet is what they do for kids
who have epilepsy and really bad
seizures and that kind of ketogenic diet
is so perfectly evolutionarily
consistent with so many other primitive
cultures this is not like it's a like
some kind of bastardized diet again this
is a very like we've eaten this way from
the beginning but think about and how
old are you 45 45 you look [ __ ] great
I do that's what you said about you
bro you look [ __ ] great yeah but
think about the uh the food trucks we
grew up with in our school it was like
carbs are number one the food uh pyramid
yeah [ __ ] in your school and they'd
feed you like peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches and fries and strawberry milk
the American dietary the American diet
has always been you know one of the most
obese countries
speaking of diet we got to bring in some
[ __ ] food yeah
hold hold yeah take out the sub Primal
and then I usually fast about 1 30. this
isn't gonna [ __ ] up your fastest why do
you fast it just makes you feel good I
don't even look at the science people
like oh you shouldn't uh it just makes
you feel good with what works for me I'm
not saying everybody should do it this
is one of the best so so uh fluids no I
love this I love a whiskey doesn't [ __ ]
up your fast no but you think testicles
will
no testicle yeah Tesco's will [ __ ]
things up yeah those are balls that's a
big old ball right there guys here's
what we're gonna do you don't gotta
throw it up I hope I'm gonna throw up I
hope you do hope you do this what you
eat every day I eat this every day and
and you do liver queen and the kids
where does that come from where is that
is that from your farm right there you
know what I I have this knee-jerk
reaction and I normally am like yeah
this is from liver King Ranch a lot of
times it is or it's from White Oak
pasture but Lionel where's this from
so liver King Charles I know
liver King Chef Lionel ensures that all
this stuff has been maintained to
specification so there's no microbial
load there's no pathogenic risk to it
there's this is no different from eating
the most pristine sushi that you're
gonna get down on so we got liver we got
testicle we got bone marrow we're not
doing a major chicotery board because
these are the most important things we
need to be getting down on inside and
that's one uh ball or is that two that's
one ball right there that's a ball wait
don't you have a ball how many balls you
got they're not that size by me yours
aren't that size I got it I got big
balls yours are that size here's our
last size
38 I mean that's about 39 yeah maybe
when you're 45 you'll get them that size
yeah they start to so let's do it let's
let's get a piece of liver what do we do
basically get all liver's a superfood
yes right you get pretty much all your
new you you get all the nutrients
somebody told me if you eat one oyster
one roister you're getting your zinc
selenium all the stuff for for the week
I mean shellfish are incredibly healthy
for you do you go fishing
do I what do you do fish shellfish and
stuff like that so every Wednesday I
just get on bone-in sardines right and I
don't know if you know this but like
when tribes were at war with one another
the landlocked tribe would call a peace
with the tribe that had access to the
fish and they would trade
because you need some of this nutrition
they would call peace treaty they would
trade and so one day a week we build
this into a system we have bone-in skin
on sardines so that we can get that kind
of nourishment yeah and so uh what else
what else yeah what else
what else from the sea are you eating
besides the sardines well that's what we
have like built into our system but like
I mean if you put some scallops or some
[ __ ] like that in front of me I'm
probably gonna oh raw
um it doesn't have to be raw here's the
thing fish gets dicey roll almost
everything that I eat most of what I eat
is cooked yeah but I don't eat organs
and glands cooked and neither do
primitive culture tribes even when they
go cook the animal when they're
butchering the animal they're harvesting
the kidney the liver the bone marrow
they're and they're eating they don't
cook that I don't cook them I only eat
muscle meat I never eat this stuff and
and you know the Messiah the Huds are
like when they're in a hunt
and and they're successful in the hunt
they eat the organs and then they throw
the muscle meat for the dogs come on
they do this they do this and and just
very stupid
this is a brand new thing it's a lack of
knowledge well Lion's the first thing
they eat is the organs they go for the
[ __ ] yes
they eat the stomach so the first thing
a lion does that the choice meal for the
lion is basically the liver the heart
the kidneys they go right for the they
tear this is the liver first right liver
that's right here's what I try to say
Reverend because a lot of people like
hey why is your name liver King and I
say it's because liver is King if you
want to be an alpha organism dominating
life do what other Alpha organisms do
better start eating the killer whale is
the ultimate predator of the sea yeah I
don't know if you guys know but they rip
open great whites and they eat their
almost their liver they deliver so a lot
of times that's what they do and there's
pods all over the world they do
different things um and there's a pod
all that goes for the stingray and
there's a big liver there's a 20 pound
liver and a stingray damn and they share
the liver right if you want to be an
alpha organism kicking out like again we
don't got to make this all count you're
like hey does it have zinc and selenium
no no no no
there's a lot of things
that's a bad impression of me too it's a
bad impression I mean do it with you let
me do it I don't talk that way dude if
if we oysters I'm not [ __ ] dude
you're being okay if we eat the oysters
don't say goods for us
I'm sorry man well what do they do sorry
what do they do right killer whales do
it Lions do it primitive culture tribes
do it we're gonna [ __ ] do it right
now let's do it I'm ready I'll try not
to throw it let's start with the liver
yeah let's not start with Tabasco sauce
all right let's go do you put any sauce
on them or like salt or that's stupid
well now I want to get it and I want to
get into why you don't need fiber
vegetables are the enemy or what
yeah you you eat that
um damn he just goes for it all right
how is it chicken [ __ ] he's a chicken
[ __ ] he's not man no can I be honest at
the end of the day
that was way better I've never eaten
liver before
hell yeah
[Music]
he's gonna throw up oh I'm good dude I'm
good I'm good no it's like uh it's like
sushi
it's like sushi you're having such a
problem your eyes are watering yeah I
almost threw up yeah it was very close
look we got these little cuts of
testicle right here I've never eaten
testicle you
squirt all over your over here it's
gonna bust all of them is it all over
your skin will look so good for the next
year or two you won't need eyelid
surgery or whatever it was I never eaten
I've never eaten [ __ ] testicle that
doesn't taste it has a very neutral
taste yeah yeah it almost tastes like
scallops now now are our testicles one
of these I I thought we were talking
about oh yeah
our testicles
the
the most testosterone
Laden meat I'm going to answer that
question but the last thing we're going
to do is a piece of bone marrow damn it
that's actually not bad bro I've never
done this how you feeling brother I'm
all right I feel stronger out there
right now that's right yeah
I've had bone marrow on toast before
yeah but cooked I've never had a rock
you like your rub no it tastes like
chalk
not very good raw no but who says it's
supposed to taste good dude you're
talking about
who said [ __ ] Health where's my
camera who's that Health look at how I'm
glowing because my Facebook teeth would
be if you ate that role
man did you get the bone marrow I have
that bone marrow is very tough yeah yeah
is it yeah it's just waxy it's waxy
right and here's the thing when it comes
out of the animal
it's perfect it's it's melty that's
probably been frozen and it gets that's
God's powdered sugar baby by the way
your Chef your Chef doesn't I mean all
due respect I'm sure you're a great cook
but you're just cutting yourself huh
you're like a Weatherman in L.A you have
the easiest gig in the world you're a
butcher you need you need a piece of
wood and a knife yeah and we're not
going to call him a chef yet we're going
to call him a butcher yeah but I'm sure
you can cook I appreciate it but uh
whenever we do serve the organs
particularly the bone marrow make sure
it's at 98 Degrees and that's whenever
you have that perfect consistency not so
chalky and very too [ __ ] cold here so
that's not 98. that's more like that was
my favorite one out of all of them
though really really I think so yeah oh
that was way less gross tonight you're
just being honest that one tastes like
scallops yeah it really does exactly you
know and this is the message I'm gonna
get out you know everybody is like so
concerned they're afraid to eat this
stuff yeah I was terrified
because undercooked meat E coli no it
was a bad trip but that's if you get it
from a feedlot that's been living in its
own [ __ ] yeah it's a cow but if you eat
a cow or anything well not even really
in that case I mean think about how
they're going to get E coli it's like
somebody in the Butcher House doesn't
wash their hands right I mean they're
not getting E coli you know well
actually what they found is that there
is a type of strain of E coli
um that that what that sort of mutated
as a result of cows getting all those
antibiotics right so then what happens
is with the antibiotics in the cow
um the the E coli mutated into a sort of
a germ resistance I mean antibiotic
resistant strain and that's what kills
people it's a it's actually a type of
bacteria that came out of the feedlots
yeah mutated so it's not a it's not a
Nature Made it's a manual bacteria I
didn't know that yeah that's why
everyone here needs a little that's what
it is yeah let's all get little ranches
and we'll be good to go that's what I'd
love to do people ask me all the time
okay so what's in the liver like you got
the zinc and the selenium the riboflavin
the bioavailable vitamin B12 the heme
iron right the choline yeah and I'm like
who [ __ ] knows what all that yeah
just eat it dude that's what I said
about you I said I don't care everybody
says hey dude fiber vegetables sure but
but whatever you're doing seems to be
working for but listen again it's not
just for me right like this is why I'm
like Hey listen I could tell you this
stuff that's in there I could tell you
the peptides that are in I could tell
you about leap too and ergothai listen
nobody wants to know that [ __ ] nobody
knows how to even compute that again
just remember if you want to if you want
to be an alpha organism a killer whale a
lion a modern day print of culture tribe
they're kicking our ass in life by the
way you look at their electricity the
way they're so fulfilled right Green
Line sleep between two hours a day but I
feel you the male lines are forever
they're very lazy yeah liver King
they're killing it yeah right and so if
you so I'm like hey you know how does
that taste and and the answer I normally
tell people is it tastes like gains it
tastes like strength it tastes like
courageous I feel stronger that's what
that tastes like you want those kind of
things how much of that would you eat
how much how much of that would you eat
uh in a day would you eat that a pound a
day what you see on your left I ate a
whole pound a day so with breakfast
lunch and dinner I have about three to
four ounces when you ever do you ever
eat yams do you ever eat anything like
[ __ ] good no he doesn't eat cereals
do you eat any cereals cereal are you
look at his face holy [ __ ] bro just I
don't eat cereal bro you would ask that
question bro do you ever have Captain
Crunch any any bread no no carbs I'm
talking to carbs you [ __ ] instigators
I do have some carbs we'll have some
potatoes oh wow thank you I was not
ready for this we'll have some potatoes
we'll have some fruit thank you wow most
of the times I I don't eat that stuff
um but it's not really about cheating so
you're with the hudza you're going on a
hunt it's a 13 Mile hunt and you know
it's life and death situation if you're
not successful it's like you have a
grocery store yeah there's not there's
no like backup plan that's your only
option this is the only option the heads
are from where from they're in Africa
they're in Africa and so here's what
ends up happening is we we came across
uh we came across a a Honey Tree what do
you call the tree Justin
bow bow
all you guys go you're so your balls
deep in this Africa jungle he he is by
the way he couldn't look more modern he
does not look like a caveman at all he
was like this he looks like he stepped
out of the Google cafeteria I'll tell
you what he's athletic as [ __ ] I can't
believe he can run I'm sure and and
these guys when they take off they take
off their he looks healthy I'm just
saying he looks very modern he doesn't
look like a caveman so they fixed that
yeah
grow a beard for guys no seriously
you're embarrassing me yeah so so what
ends up happening is um you know now you
mention it I don't know if you've heard
of this but you know opportunity is a
moving Target when it's right in front
of you you better Goddamn seize it they
come across this tree they realize that
this is the jackpot for honey and they
start pulling out honeycomb and there's
bees African bees and they're stinging
they're all over they're all over and
then they tell me hey liver King and and
come get in this tree and I look over
and I look at everybody I'm like [ __ ] my
wife is here my kids are everyone's here
here and and I always teach if you get
an opportunity to do something you
always do it sees them regret what you
do I don't like bees bro so oh me
neither I love honey though [ __ ] bees
I'm like blue
they're all over me they're [ __ ]
seriously all over me and I'm I'm trying
to pretend like I'm cool you know but
they're all cameras are on us the
cameras are on yeah I'm like oh we
should search it up it's awesome
I wish we had a computer
story I want to hear the story there's
bees all over me
um but here's the thing
um this is very evolutionarily
consistent also eating honey having the
occasional fruit right these are things
that that we would have had in the wild
not year round we would have never had
this stuff year round right but we
absolutely had access to it and again
when this is right in front of you and
you don't know where your calories are
coming from you're going to get down on
this stuff yeah yes so you're an
opportunistic eater in other words if
the fruit is ripe and it's right there
you're gonna eat it if there's honey
you're gonna eat it we have an orchard
at liver King Ranch if I have something
growing in the orchard I'm gonna I'm
gonna take a peach off of that tree I
love it oh yeah and I'm gonna I'm gonna
ask a liver King Chef Lionel to make a
[ __ ] what did you make with the
peaches last time
but it was it wasn't just oh here it is
right here wasn't that it
now now
um I was reaching into a tree
what a life this is awesome you're
living your life exactly the way you
want it and giving your kids the best
education period thank you for saying
that um because we got a lot of [ __ ]
about it really or would you guys pay
attention to this people are jealous you
guys read competency well no listen we
uh
we've had CPS call on us right because
because they think this is child support
oh there it is right there oh but but if
you're now are these Africans are these
African bees look at these concerns look
at these guys and these guys they're
they're stung all over well they're
getting stung and they don't care and
they're in Skunk cats look at this he's
got to be on his shoulder right now
are they stinging the [ __ ] out of you
yeah yeah but you're acting like yeah
yeah because they're not showing him
half an African Beast stinging the [ __ ]
out of you and you were okay
do you hear how they talk yeah they're
they're wearing Yeezy season seven
that's cool
you pretend you understand what they're
saying or what you say my name what are
you gonna do oh you got a translator
what are you gonna say hey man I don't
[ __ ] understand your state again I'd
say text me
so now now
um how many times you get stung I don't
know how many times but but here but I
just want to answer that question the
overwhelming majority of what we eat is
carnivorous yeah and and then we
supplement that yeah with some fish well
we'll have some carbohydrates I have
maple syrup I have maple syrup so um and
if you think about this we always had
carbs if you drink fresh blood it's full
of glucose if you have a fresh organ
it's full of glycogen yeah liver that
was harvesting or that was filtering
blood that same day you eat into it and
it's sweet what but but we've drained
all that stuff out and we're conditioned
to have that stuff that you buy you know
at the whatever grocery store without so
we we do need some of that stuff I don't
over indulge in it but again if it's in
front of me I'm gonna think about it is
this evolutionarily consistent how am I
feeling did I earn that [ __ ] and a lot
of people say hey how many carbs should
I eat and I'm like hey that's the wrong
question did you earn your carbs and if
you earned your [ __ ] carbs you
probably have an idea maybe let's take a
little break let's hit let's we're
talking about nutrition we're talking
about supplements we're talking about
how to be how to optimize your health if
you don't have time to be a caveman you
still want great supplements and you
want to be in the zone dude you want to
listen good brain health listen we all
want to be caveman but you want to be a
smart caveman you want to be able to
form sentences like Joe Rogan you're
like what's he using Alpha Brain yeah
I'm on it right I never said I've never
seen you do a podcast without alphabet
not ever yeah yep it's a world-renowned
nootropic supplement with over 1 million
bottles sold all right Alpha Brain
promotes cognitive function including
memory mental speed and focus can help
you remember names which I struggle with
zero in on complex tasks you're gonna
think more clearly under stress like you
said Joe Rogan says that it helps them
form better sentences it releases it
releases alpha waves that can they're
associated with greater creativity yeah
but B let me guess you want to take it
because caffeine cool man there's no
caffeine in it you don't have to worry
about the jittery feeling listen this is
how sure Anna is of Alpha Brain if you
don't love it you get your money back no
questions asked they send it right back
no return necessary you're all taken
care of dude save 10 off your order by
going to onnit.com
f-a-t-k get 10 off that's on it.com
slash f-a-t-k or swing by your local
Walmart and pick some up but don't go to
Walmart go to audit.com f-a-t-k Alpha
Brain on it there's nothing better when
you go to the doctor when you go to the
doctor and you get a checkup what are
you looking at your blood work what do
you what are you looking for Doctor dude
hey let's all laugh out loud do you like
my question hey can you tell he grew up
rich
you can tell so when you're on your
private chat does the doctor I read
about this I I was on two safaris before
I was six that was you right you've been
up here
well my daddy but but but no do you do
you go to the doctor do you get blood
work done do you what do you do it looks
in the mirror I mean this is what I say
if you're kicking ass in life right if
you have great energy if you like how
you look feel and function if you got a
kicking ass libido why the [ __ ] I don't
know what about what about this what
about uh a clogged artery what about uh
uh cholesterol things like that well
first of all the whole cholesterol myth
is is just that right that's a proxy to
something that we hardly understand more
people die with normal cholesterol more
people have heart attacks with normal
cholesterol than with high cholesterol
if you want to really know about your
cardiac health and I'm not saying I'm a
cardiac expert right but like we got to
ask these questions right it's what
what's your fasting insulin what's your
hsrp what are your inflammatory markers
look like what are your triglycerides
what are your blood pressure that's why
you go to a doctor
they do a prescription again
you just came up with a bunch of things
that where you can go to a doctor and
find those things out if you want to
know specifically about your cardiac
health right if you're kicking ass in
life go Kick-Ass in life you see what
you look for you recognize what you know
how much you want to bet you go to a
doctor they're going to tell you how to
fix it they're going to tell you and
they're going to make Medicare and
Medicaid this is how they put you on a
Statin do you know what cholesterol
lowering drugs due to your testosterone
it's not good for you the side effects
of those drugs are insane on average
yeah on average what they do to you
listen we already have a whole
population with low testosterone guess
what now we're going to put you on a
cholesterol lowering medication that's
going to lower it even more mass
Shooters we're gonna dig we're gonna
decrease I think antacids do that too
things like oh antacids are horrifices
like just like antacids like that like a
different ones you can take like they
for heartburn and stuff like that even
those have an effect on your
testosterone those really so there's a
lack of sleep so there's a lack of sun
anti-ass is really [ __ ] up the the
stomach and you can't digest I would
assume like it has to do with just even
digesting nutrients in order to make
testosterone like if you're [ __ ] up
with your digestion you can't oh it's
awesome food that's right that's right
you know so the main thing is listen if
you've got a legitimate reason to go go
and I'm not against acute medicine I
think it's incredible you know I think
someone in here I think your mom had a
spiral fracture was it a female yeah or
femur uh Striker had similar thing and
you're gonna love this uh
UFC fight it was Matt Hughes and uh
Gracie oh boy and I'm like and and uh
I'm like hot second ago yeah so you guys
are UFC fans we are and here's the thing
I heard you tell Patty penley should be
eating uh
but by the way nobody [ __ ] knows that
the guy interviewing me he's the one who
brought that [ __ ] up okay I heard you
told him to eat liver and like like
multiple things are in us and also
testicles he's like testicles and then
that was the kind of the thing that they
really exactly because For the record if
you're kicking ass in life if you're
winning who the [ __ ] am I to tell you
what to do right but if you got an
opportunity could use some of your
advice though as far as dieting though
you know he's the guy that blows up
between fights but why why is that bad
uh it's back because he's 27 he fights
at 155 and he was on my show food truck
he's probably over 200 pounds so the
problem is is that extreme weight cut
all the time and why is that bad uh
because the the what it does to the body
so when he's going from so so much
easier if he because a lot of guys say
they fight at 55 a lot of them around
170-ish 175 so you're cutting 20 pounds
which is acceptable to cut you know 50
pounds 60 pounds it's just that strain
on the body if you got a finite amount
of time you can do that right you know
like I always say if you're always ready
you're always [ __ ] ready like I don't
have to cut weight I mean whatever I
weighs whatever and that's out Cheetos
that way Tony Fergus there's a lot of
guys who are that way they're like I
just trained whether I have a fight or
not and I eat a Clean Diet just my
lifestyle they're like it's not a camp
it's a lifestyle it's like Cheeto walk
you know he's not a big dude he's just
always in shape so so for the record I
didn't come out and prospectively say
some stupid [ __ ] like I watched it I
watch it you should you start doing I
saw the headline no you give him a whole
interview and then all they did is
highlight you know liver King says tells
Patty testicles I'm like that's not
they're trying to start a fight here's a
date well that's they're doing views
right they're doing a few things yeah
yeah yeah so so to that end his name is
Striker for that reason we have been UFC
fans for a long time it was one of our
first dates we went to the Staples
Center to do that thing and um Striker
had a spiral fracture and like I said
you're gonna like this how do you get it
um he was doing a handstand walk just
growing like like a weed and then comes
down he's twisting and it was just the
inertia and um what ends up happening is
he's like screaming bloody murder and we
don't take our kids anywhere they don't
go to the doctor right so he's screaming
bloody murder and I'm like hey man you
can sleep on it and and uh no no tile at
all no aspirin nothing oh wow you're
gonna sleep on it he doesn't sleep you
know he doesn't sleep a second he
doesn't sleep at all and thank God we
rent space to to uh uh some surgeons
that have these machines and I'm like
okay the next day I'm like okay we're
gonna take you we're just gonna check it
out we're gonna check it out and so we
checked it out and the way the surgeon
looked at me when he saw the X-ray I
could see in his face and I was like oh
my I'll never forget that you felt like
a child abuser yeah and and then and
then here's the thing I'll try to make
this quick every surgeon said hey
surgery you need surgery and you do all
this [ __ ] we found a surgeon and say Hey
you know you can try and do it on your
own and with what we know I'm like I bet
we could fix this [ __ ] and uh and so
um finally a surgeon said hey you got a
non-union fracture it's not healing
surgery if you don't do surgery right
now he ain't never going to walk again
normal like I don't [ __ ] believe you
man I don't believe you we took him
somewhere else the same day the same a
different surgeon same day
um says he can come out of the cast he's
going to walk out of here today
is what we did right and thank God
Striker could be part of this experience
right because listen we asked the
questions everyone is incentivized and
listen maybe every surgeon every doctor
is well intentioned fine good right I I
believe a lot of them are but but this
is not irrespective of intention and
motivation we all still I'll have to
provide for our families right so I'm so
glad Striker understands hey man we push
back we ask questions we get second and
third opinions yes that day he walked
out damn and he's kicking ass he's
athletic as hell he's grown like a weed
yeah yeah so to I'm gonna answer the
question acute medicine is amazing all
for it right but long-term stuff right
you go to the doctor you say hey man run
some tests on me I don't care how
healthy you are how much you want to bet
they're gonna find something going on
yeah how much you want to bet they got
something to give you right how much you
want to bet most the time you're gonna
take you're gonna buy what they're
selling right then you're gonna be
dealing with another problem that's what
they don't tell you about oh those come
with other problems what's like Rogan
had that horrible uh shoulder he's
started doing they told everyone told
them you have to have uh surgery you
have to have surgery he's like I don't
know about surgery man and then he got
the stem cell and he's not he can lift
full he does full kettlebell movement
now his shoulder's better I know a lot
of guys that just they go away from
surgeon they're against stem cells now
yeah instead of the full-blown surgery I
like I like studying the call ERS though
the Blues
where people live forever Sardinia
Seventh-day Adventist uh Okinawa uh yeah
they live the longest they all the one
thing they all do is they do there's a
lot more to health than just food but
you know Community
um they're connected to their Community
uh they do some kind of movement if it's
walking gardenings they're always
physical in the sun yep to this point
they eat a fermented usually eats
something fermented usually some kind of
a fermented like a yogurt of some kind
they all eat meat actually the only exam
exception is the Seventh-day Adventist
but they all eat some kind of they have
low sperm um
well there you go maybe maybe but who
are you talking about is this and you
got to be careful with these isolated
examples because sometimes it's like but
I I to your point they they for the most
part
um it's a comprehensive way of living
they're in the sun they're walking
they're gardening they have tight
Community there's no Outlet
none of them are going to have over a 30
inch vertical you know what I'm saying
like I don't know yeah that's like yeah
fishermen they they they you know what
I'm saying yeah if you kind of that's
the other thing is if you're an athlete
uh there are a lot of people the Olympic
if you look at the people who train
Olympic athletes from other countries
right like the Russians like the Chinese
yeah so the Chinese had their diving
team up their beef consumption yeah
because and and if you talk to those
athletes that have to see results in
their athletes explosion power and stuff
like that
I don't know of any and this is not me
but I've heard other people who've
studied this there are no none of those
coaches that are going to tell you to
put your your I know there are
exceptions to put your Athlete on a
vegan diet they're all eating your
example is China and Russia also
steroids of course of course but they're
also but diet is also a huge part of it
for them like how you eat on an ongoing
basis how you eat when you're when
you're for Recovery uh you know after
your training they're very specific
about that stuff so to your point the
blue zones they're doing most of the
nine ancestral tenants yeah they are
they are and and again like we we should
look at these things modern day
primitive culture tribes and blue zones
and it's not just about lifespan [ __ ]
lifespan this is about health span it's
about the life you live while you're
here yeah you want to live to 90 and you
can't use your dick right or would you
rather live to 70. kicking [ __ ] ass
and going going to hell in a rocket ship
yeah that's that is that is a big and a
very important question I was going to
ask you that yeah longevity is one thing
longevity is one thing where you you can
like you know you can do your thing and
move at a slow pace and live to your
100. but I always feel like it's a
little bit like you're in second gear
it's like they talk about they talk
about meditation I get it you could be
in a cave and meditate and live till
you're 120. I don't really want to live
my life that way I want to die young and
leave a good looking corpse I want to do
everything I want to [ __ ] do I'm a
Great Dane I mean I'll be the first one
to die here that's fine well again if
you look at modern day primitive culture
tribes they seemingly have no material
possessions right I mean they got like
bows and they got Spears they have
weapons right but they don't have any of
these modern day possessions like we
have they're the happiest most content
most fulfilled most electric I've said
this before it's like the chemistry that
they have you put this on any
professional sports team you win a Super
Bowl every time yep
it's incredible they also don't have
access though right like their ignorance
is bliss like they've not like I'm sure
if you gave a freaking Native American a
Ferrari like Jesus crisis thing is cool
we're with the machine gun we're with
the matching again there's a true story
oh we're so spoiled we brought like all
of our our water with this bottle glass
bottled water to the Amazon you're done
with all the roads you're done with all
the electricity we're going 10 hours on
a river boat in the Amazon past all that
[ __ ] and we bring cases of glass bottled
water this water right here and that's
only water you drink right uh well we
have well water you know like where
we're at like we'll drink you know yeah
but there's something about that so I
don't know if it's true but I've read it
several times that when Western settlers
in with the Indian uh the Indian
American wars would happen when a
western settler a European would go to
and be an indoctrinated into an Indian
tribe they never came back all right oh
because they loved it so much yes
whereas when an Indian was brought in oh
even if they were kidnapped they would
be kidnapped and they still wanted to
say even I don't know if that's true but
but I've read that many times that was
something that was pretty well
documented same and so we're done we're
done hanging out with the matching hey
goodbye it's great thank you for caring
in my water all these miles see guys now
right and listen I can't give you guys
[ __ ] because money does nothing there's
like what can you give them absolutely
nothing all they wanted was a bottle of
water talk about ignorance is bliss they
wanted one of these bottles of water
okay cool man here you go guys you're
welcome man and what do you think
happens next
they drank it and used the bottle for
something they don't know how to open it
ignorance is completely Bliss you give
them a Ferrari you give them whatever
you know like wild the things that
actually make us happy Tony Robbins said
this um there's one word that's
synonymous for happy it's progress right
and so I say this every Friday happy
hour's overrated right if you get
yourself into the gym if you do push-ups
before dinner then you know progress you
know happy on a physical front if you
put down the damn phone if you do this
sort of connecting with people if you
deepen your bond then you know happy you
know progress on a social and emotional
level if you read a new book if you
learn a new skill if you use abstract
thinking to solve a new problem you know
happy on an intellectual level right and
if you go deep inside yourself right and
if you contemplate whether or not we
have souls or if we just are souls right
and if if it's possibly time and space
that we use to interface with our
Consciousness you ask these questions
and you make progress with your
spirituality you know happy on a
spiritual level right and so it's it's
as simple as this this progress is built
into their way of living every day and
and so they make progress on all four
capacities in their holistic being so if
we can bring this into our everyday
living right I mean today but what if
you can't like what if you people get so
busy that they haven't got time what
supplements do you recommend yeah like I
don't have [ __ ] none to have a
charcuterie board you know what I mean
I'm not saying that's actually takes
less time and it's not as expensive
actually as a lot of food right right
but so it's like it's expensive to be
healthy actually so I would say two
things number one like I feel like those
are all subprimal excuses because
um the kind of life you're gonna live
when you can start so I tell everyone go
on a hunt go make this kind of
connection make the [ __ ] time to do
it because when you make this connection
with the land and the animal you'll
never look at this kind of stuff the
same way if you can't do that go to your
butcher go to your farmer's market if
you can't do that go to White Oak
pastures go to piedmontese these are
places you can order it um are you sure
you want to put that Invisalign back in
oh wow
it's called the whole Feast right and so
say you don't want to eat this stuff
listen at some point you got to get this
nourishment into your diet I don't care
who you are or where you are if you're
not going to eat liver if you're not if
you're not going to cook this stuff or
if you're not going to procure it if
you're not going to put this stuff down
your throat every day you have to get
this in your diet and so again I just
told you how to do it go on a hunt go to
the butcher go do all those things if
you're not going to do all those things
I got another solution for you it's
called the whole feast or you can buy a
supplement version right but let's taste
this let's see what it tastes like this
is your stuff what am I drinking I'll
tell you I'm then I'm gonna tell you
what's in it but first we're going to
take it so primal
let's do it man thanks bro cheers boys
thank you what is that drinking hit the
shake yeah you're drinking the shake
what is that it's called whole Feast
just drink it yeah I don't care you got
your Invisalign in just [ __ ] drink it
don't even take the Invisalign out dude
uh the reason why I gave this juice
because I saw you put that [ __ ] back in
cheers ah it tastes like chocolate
um now that's nice that's tasty so yeah
that's also better than I expect because
I've had a lot of shitty protein powders
since you know the 90s when I started
drinking it and I would drink that so a
whole Feast has liver heart pancreas
spleen blood bones and colostrum in
there it all it also has why are you
making that face no I it just it's that
Grayson oh that sounds different that
was nice but and here's the thing you've
got to get we evolved eaten this stuff
we recently took this out of our diet to
our detriment and so I want to create
access and make sure everyone has that
again I'm telling you the totem pole go
on hunt go on go to the butcher go do
these things can I just buy that bagger
you can just buy that [ __ ] well first
of all you can have that bag yeah I'm
gonna take that bag what is in this bag
oh this is the oh this is yeah pancreas
grass man whole Beast blend beef protein
isolated beef organ powder heart liver
kidney spleen pancreas damn
it
and for the record I'm gonna plug it
again it's called the whole feast and
every day here where can we get that oh
there's a website called the fit you can
get on Amazon do you count do you
calculate protein I think it just
delivers every month yeah dude 216 grams
of protein per serving 260 21 Grams
younger you know what your eyesight
would be better
I got eyesight dude I want to apologize
for that sub Primal eyesight subpromal
teeth it's just beta energy over there
I'm gonna move in with you what kind of
well let me let me work for you I'll
just have a job you know what I'll do
I'll butter your beard I'll put in your
beard nobody [ __ ] touches it nobody
knows
bro liver Queen takes a machete to it
twice a year but you know I don't know
if you guys know Mark Bell Mark Bell was
out there yeah let me know more guns
Mark comes over you might create them
from him so Mark comes over to be out of
nowhere again we're shooting guns like
and and then we have our shirts off and
then uh of course I'm gonna start off
and Mark comes over to me and he's going
like this I see like coming up to my abs
but what the [ __ ] are you doing and and
he looks at he's taping all this stuff
you know and he goes hey I'm just taping
one to see if they're real are you
kidding me I said listen I said I don't
allow another [ __ ] man to touch me
without my permission yeah get the [ __ ]
away yeah and he goes I just want to see
if they're implants and I was like are
you kidding me is this actually plants
yeah I mean the accusations that have
happened today I mean I could listen
that's how you know you're doing well
though I appreciate it you're doing well
again I have fun with it you're a
muscular [ __ ] I mean you must
work out like a maniac well the
questions are all the same and I do I
work out twice a day every day you know
even on my off days I take Wednesday and
Sunday off I still do abs for one hour
on my off day that's a whole hour it's
so long way too much it's so extra yeah
it is and it's how I'm wired but but
this is the deal you know at first so so
the questions have always been the same
right so the ants I've always told the
truth so the answers are always the same
right
um I I still don't take this stuff right
never did I still don't right and then
it was about it and this became a real
thing AB implants and abetching this
became a real thing I'm like okay for
the record still I've never had it done
I don't do it right and the guy didn't
take his son to the hospital he broke
his [ __ ] like you think he's going
under the knife and then someone said no
well you shaved your chest I don't
[ __ ] shave my chest I don't shave my
abs you know people like oh you you're
you're manicured in some way guess what
I don't [ __ ] don't I don't shave my
balls he's got some good hair what is
your nationality what is your what do
you where do you what is I'm gonna
answer that but I want to finish I want
to finish because I would assume when
you came onto the scene everyone's like
oh it's just steroids because that's the
easy right that's easy out because they
don't look like you so but don't do that
to anybody athletes you know like uh you
know Aaron judge on this home run uh
path everyone's like well you know I'd
be interested to see you know how
steroids like what the f it's just their
way of coping with some people are just
born better dude
I'm sorry people talked about this for
about six to nine months and then it
became about AB implants and then it
became it was like oh liver King wore a
hat and then he stopped wearing a hat he
got hair implants this is like a real
thing and then if it came about I don't
know if you guys have heard this that I
went to Singapore in 2018 to tap my
myostatin Gene edited I had Gene editing
down I heard about that by the way I
invented that one to have little fun the
only accusation that's true I have a
pre-World War II device
it's from Russia it's it's a muscle
shock therapy machine that I use I also
invented this up right this I'm [ __ ]
with everybody
I am gonna earlier you're like hey
you're having fun with it yeah yeah I'm
wild I'm free on Prime we were born
these Wild free don't give a [ __ ]
undomesticated people you don't need a
drink right when you're Wild and Free
having a good time so I'm gonna be wild
and free and I'm gonna have fun with it
but all the accusations it's like you
know what I'm okay making this a little
side dish but let's not forget like the
reason why I fight today is the reason
why I unite is because people are
actually really hurting 85 of people
have self-esteem issues eighty percent
struggle paycheck to paycheck they spend
more money than they make because we
think that we can express our worth
value and potential with [ __ ] that we
buy with shoes with watches with cars
and Handbags look at how valuable I am
look at what I bought right and why do
we think that we can do that instead of
building value inside that stacks and
compounds seventy percent of people are
overweight half of will be 50 on
medication forty percent have or will
get cancer and twenty percent of the
population is infertile this is why I'm
here today right this is what I fight
for you tell me what day of the week we
should be talking about my hair implants
tell me what day of the week we should
be talking about ped accusations listen
that's what's funny people want to play
this gotcha game I don't know
we were like I don't give a [ __ ] the guy
is fantastic how about that how about
celebrating this [ __ ] who's
eating raw [ __ ] and bringing this whole
this example of living the way he wants
that's what we celebrate I do not give a
[ __ ] if you've got 15 needles in here I
don't care and I don't that's why we're
I wasn't going to bring that up or talk
about that I don't [ __ ] care but as I
noticed that you look pretty [ __ ]
good and whatever you're doing is
working so that's why you could use that
advice and your energy and your your
message as well you're giving this your
kids but I also think a lot of people
don't have perspective like if they've
never been in a locker room or they've
never been around people are just
genetically Gifted Man like obviously
your your genetics are pretty [ __ ]
good well I saw a picture when they were
young I saw a picture
I was 15 in that picture and here's what
people don't know yeah it's got a nice
picture I had already been doing bench
press for seven years when I was eight
years old I started doing bench press
and I was just drawn to it I figured out
that this was it right like I wish
somebody told me what I was 15. that's a
strong kid I mean that's crazy a very
well developed chest thank you for
saying that you look at my brother my
brother looks absolutely but my brother
wasn't creating that resistance I needed
that res and again all men are driven to
have this what do we do when when men
turned 16 years old today
we throw them a sweet 16 party you guys
right if you look at the Machi genga
Spartans
it's very [ __ ] beta right every
ancestral tribe permanent culture tribe
they have a real rite of passage they
will advance in gloves I love that story
what right and and we do something
sure hundreds of ants sewn into sewn
into these grass myths and they they
they douse them in this solution that
makes them tired and then you sew them
ass ass backwards okay and then you put
your hands in and say wake up as they
wake up
hundreds of bullet ants which is the
most painful I freaked out over one
yellow jacket sting they [ __ ]
hundreds of them will sting your hands
right there yeah now you go ahead and
try that but every but that purification
rituals
I love it I love it again comfort's not
good for the organism what their teach
teaching here is that you can endure
something that that you otherwise
thought was impossible and when you
learn how to do this thing so I created
a workout called Barbarian it's the
equivalent of a rite of passage that I
brought into the modern world I made
Striker do it before right before he
turned 15. nobody thought he could do it
right nobody thought he didn't think he
could do it but I know that when you can
train the barbarian when you become the
Barbarian then you know true strength
what is it and I'm going to tell you and
when you know true strength it's not
just about your ability to impose your
force of wealth physically you go do
Barbarian you don't wake up one day and
just do Barbarian right you train for
barbarian you complete Barbarian you've
completed a modern day rite of passage
that you otherwise thought was
impossible and you realize it's that
process the act of suffering the
struggling the discipline the Relentless
Focus to continue to do this when you
accomplish Barbarian what you know with
any other Rite of passages holy [ __ ] I
can point that process at anything as a
boss in a relationship at any role and
goal I have in life and that's when you
develop that true strength so this is
what we used to do to our detriment
we've abandoned a rite of passage and so
this is what I think is is really
important is we bring this back the
Barbarian is a workout where you have 70
pounds in a backpack 70 pound
kettlebells you have 120 pounds on top
of a 45 or 65 pound sled you have 20
pound ankle weights you go for one mile
so it's one mile this is Barbarian for
most people it's going to be an
incredible rite of passage you would
crush it so you're only you you would
only even think about doing super
Barbarian you're not even invited he's a
horse
you and I do super barbarians people
that have done super Barbarian liver
Queen's one of them super Barbarian is
with super Barbarian super Barbarian is
is um how much do you wear a testicles 2
45 right now okay so you're gonna have
130 pound kettlebells in each hand okay
that's a lot of weight you're going to
have the set your same weight 260 pounds
on the sled you're still gonna have 20
pound sleds behind me yeah I'm pulling
the sled holding the dumbbells that's
right gotcha you still go a mile a pill
or is it flat it's it's like life it's
Austin that's ridiculous though it's
like I mean I'd fly out to uh Austin do
that I'll be down for that okay yeah
dude you're doing that that's that's
crazy shape that's [ __ ] nuts and so
that's the deal that's Barbarian
there's no pictures of me doing super
Barbarian because this this is a just a
rite of passage that you go out and you
it's a very spiritual thing I mean
everything leaves your body everything
is gone everything is [ __ ] gone you
guys
and so this is the deal is that we've
evolved with these Rites of passages and
today
we wonder why men are suffering with
such desperation like why are men so
aimlessly wandering around weak and
submissive and I'll tell you why it's
because Hard Times make strong men and
there's no requirement for hard times at
the modern world and comfort we get warm
we turn down the thermostat yeah right
like we Outsource any hard work right
food today you want food it's in your
refrigerator the Huds have to go hunt
you know 13 miles so when you just talk
to me a little bit about cold I'm up
coward when it comes to the cold when
it's a little chilly um
I wear scarves I bundle the [ __ ] up yeah
thank God
in Boston I gotta keep my necky wacky
warm what the [ __ ] is wrong with that
I can't do anything right I want
perfectly straight teeth and I want to
keep my necky wacky warm what is wrong
with that I gotta get I gotta get Primal
dude to your point though as far as
tough times tough people it's also
because Society is going away from that
the alpha males like yourself and others
they're they're becoming Public Enemy
Number One because people don't want to
condone that you know that behavior so
like no no no we gotta silence these
guys we like obedience yes everything's
easier and guess what we hate ourselves
we hate the lives when someone's free
and they're living their own it's not
even that the independence whatever it's
it's if you're a successful you know
male alpha male societies now especially
Hollywood and you know the big media
corporations and social media is like no
that's not what we want to hear because
they want to you know make it the [ __ ]
like you're saying they want to sell you
something yes and guess what everyone's
buying it everybody but my question is
how's that working for you guys like
your people are miserable you just went
over all the stats like how if we keep
going down this road how's that go for
us yeah I want to say my solution is
pretty simple start with liver it's
really that simple right if you start
with liver this will give you more drive
more determination more energy to take
Massive Action and to kick ass in life
because because why because it's a wow
with your subjects
because of your because liver is a
complete food it's superfood is that
what it is you mean you're getting most
of your nutrients when you eat liver
well it's not only are you getting most
of them you're getting the nutrition
that has been left out of your diet
these are the things that we evolved
with again you can eat them every day
without getting uh vitamin A toxicity
and all that well the fat soluble
vitamins live in the system if you get
enough d and e and K you're gonna be
fine this is why I said earlier most
people I say
maybe get a pound a week a pound a week
I do a pound a day right but but I also
eat bone marrow every day I get to the
Sun every day right I eat egg yolks
every day just do that somewhere though
yeah and so start eating liver and this
is going to give you more drive more
determination better neurochemistry to
start kicking ass in life but now you
got to learn the Barbarian train the
Barbarian become the barbarian when you
do that you'll know what it is to impose
your force of will are you ever sick you
have the flu or cold or anything you
know what if I don't feel good
again to me it's like I'm not going to
lay up in bed and be you know what I do
is I go on a five day water only fast
and I don't eat for a week zero calories
say everybody gets exposed to different
paths well here's the thing I don't I
live in a primal vacuum I live in a
primal bubble so when I go out and I'm
interacting with you guys and we're
hugging because I'm gonna [ __ ] hug
everybody yeah you're gonna get monkey
Heart to Heart yeah I got I got my
monkey pox when you get back to us and I
got no antibodies to the [ __ ]
subprimal [ __ ] you're giving me right
you didn't get whatever new covered
strain in Monkey box so most of the time
I'm pretty resilient to it um everyone
said I'll say once or twice a year I
don't feel good yeah and you know what
I'm like what a gift this is because I
don't ever take time off from the gym
and and what I'm gonna do now is I'm
gonna take five days where I don't work
out I'm not gonna eat anything and the
kind of benefit I get from it I'm not
sure if you know about the benefits of
fasting but apoptosis autophagy you get
mitochondrial biogenesis metabolic
flexibility disease prevention and
Remediation even if you don't know you
have [ __ ] this is all good stuff this
this is all like cancer prevention you
have in essence cells that always want
to destroy themselves apoptosis right
but we just we we never give ourselves
what's built into our evolutionary past
a break from eating mtor's always
activated it's always activated there's
a condition that way right but well
because we eat breakfast lunch and
dinner somebody said hey you got to do
this thing people eat breakfast lunch
and dinner then they have snacks in
between before and after so you'll
you'll you'll fast twice a year or you
fast we've asked every quarter and if I
don't feel good prior to that happening
it's like you know what we're going to
take we're gonna take a break right now
how many calories you take anything you
I mean I don't measure them yeah um and
I don't want to say because one time I
said something and some some genius from
YouTube is like let me tell you why
that's impossible yeah yeah I I don't
count them um but here's how I kind of
deal with my calories if I feel like I'm
I'm getting less ripped then all I do is
is lay off the maple syrup dial it down
yeah yeah that's it it's like carbs is
my lever if I feel like I'm getting less
swoll then I just lay on the maple syrup
but even more I'm sure the liver is
pretty calorie dense right I mean if you
guys were to see what would I actually
if I make a story of it every single day
here's what liver Kings have for dinner
it's a it's a robust dinner I would tell
you my dinner at least has 3 000
calories every day just my dinner which
is hard to do if you're not eating carbs
um I don't think it is because fat is so
it again double the calories per gram
yeah and if you look at the amount of
fat that we have and that's
evolutionarily consistent like in a
piece of meat you know and then we'll
add like some some homemade butter on
that and we're eating a bunch of eggs
um it's not often you tap a vein of one
of your animals how do we do it how
often and how do you do it oh um you
know if you come to town we'll do it
like we usually do it when we're having
a guess or if we're not feeling good
[ __ ] yeah where is this place it's
between Houston and Dallas
yeah we live we live in the boonies
between Houston and Dallas I'd love to
come out yeah we have 500 Acres out
there and it's just we love going out
there we have all of our animals we have
we have the egg Department we have the
milk Department we got the meat
department we have the Wilderness
Department you know and every Saturday
we'll usually do a dose of mushrooms
which I'm sure we'll talk about oh hell
yeah I'm all about that good he recently
got into it yeah
if I start doing psychedelics about a
convertible yellow Corvette
it was right here actually it's a second
Mark's on the road with me he'll wake up
because we I always get an Airbnb when
I'm on tour we'll wake up I'll do I
don't know how much of those mushrooms
down an energy drink there's no way
every day every day it's a Madman yeah
why do you get an Airbnb by the way uh
hotels give me PTSD from fighting yeah I
can't sleep alone okay well and how much
you want to bet like you're so much
better protective I mean a hotel has
I don't know a hundred or a thousand
different modems and routers and you can
be way better off than I do every space
too it's way better it's a house it's
easy it's more comfortable you're really
excited about the mushrooms I am could
you share why uh because I I believe
that I've never ever done mushrooms and
even had really bad trips where it
didn't push me closer to the truth
meaning where I didn't want to reconcile
anything in my life that wasn't uh where
I wasn't being completely honest where I
wasn't completing those circles whether
it was a relationship that needed to be
mended or whatever you call people yes
or I I have
all right all this [ __ ] I've done for
this dude I haven't I haven't called you
yet but there's something about uh the
psilocybin trip that feels incredibly
positive and more importantly I think
that it I think it brings to the
Forefront the subconscious part of
yourself you're not confronting maybe
that's what it is right so uh Carl Jung
said if you don't bring from the
subconscious to the conscious
if you don't bring your subconscious the
things in your subconscious you don't
know are there to the conscious it will
act out of Spate in your life and I
think there's something about as I get
older aligning yourself with the truth
regardless now do you do the mushrooms
with your uh
five more weeks and I'm gonna have the
straightest teeth and then what they
call it the dose the because
I I support it you know I'm not I'm not
a big guy in any facet I support it
especially if they enjoy doing it I
don't give a [ __ ] but if it helps them
great I Disappeared another song yeah it
means 55 saying it's weird but um you
did it but what you did what the heroes
dose plus that the three the three grams
is great when you get into six grams you
did six grams this first time oh your
first time well no I done it because I
got mushrooms before when I was younger
you couldn't stop farting yeah I was
doing a lot of things there were a lot
of things that seems pretty primal
private
babe can I just call something up the
psilocybin versus ssris is this
something that you think about I don't
know anything about ssris really okay
well this has an antidepressant or
something you could take like because I
micro dose at another basis and the
first thing that I'll tell people is
like when you take a pinch this I just
put my fingers and go like this it's a
mood enhancer you could sort of swap it
out with cow take it with caffeine but
ideally I'd like to take less caffeine
and maybe a little more psilocybin
mushrooms but I am just observing it's a
mood enhancer yeah that's interesting uh
here's the thing
we've been such persistent evolutionary
hunters in opposite directions that
Monday will go through Sunday and we
never really grow or progress our
relationship and then when we introduce
mushrooms it was like oh every Saturday
we're gonna spend 10 hours on the top of
our Mountain together together so you
guys do a real dose just you and uh
we'll do about your dose yeah it's just
the two of us you just go up there and
kids are like well Mom Dad are you gone
for the day I want to come that's right
hold on when they know you do it you do
you're not invited dude six grams we're
coming in that's right let me in I want
in on the Genie bottle because you're in
a Genie bottle and you do that [ __ ]
you're just in this Dimension bro I'm
gonna do it no absolutely not
um I just don't feel like doing it but
um
you live this you know this the caveman
lifestyle a little bit you know we talk
about caveman the evolution stuff like
that but they also weren't monogamous
how did you subscribe to that well
there's a lot of these tribes that were
monogamous and if you look at the
parental investors am I right
yeah but you know this is not
appropriate but but here's the thing you
know people talk about this stuff right
and and some tribes weren't monogamous
some sometimes weren't monog and if you
look at modern day print of culture
tribes right um and the parental
investment that's required right if
you're really going to want to raise
somebody and really impart and instill
those types of values I think it's
important and here's another thing I
think is important to to understand with
the tribes that were not monogamous do
you know who chose your next wife
your parents it was usually your first
wife chose your second wife and so she's
just picking warlocks who do you think
she's choosing the ugliest girl in the
truck and now does this fat girl the one
fat girl on the tribe how attractive
situation to you now well then I'm like
you know what I'm good I'm just gonna go
back to the web that's the thing and I
like to talk about this because uh a lot
I don't know why but people ask me you
know about relationship advice and uh
and at first I'm like oh God I'm not
gonna do well you guys have a great
relationship you're around each other
all the time you're going to Africa
you're in Amazon you're getting married
18 years Jesus I'll listen to you go
ahead well I'm listening
so so this is you know first time I
thought okay you know do I really want
to give do I want to start embarking on
this kind of advice and then I thought
you know what this is important um
there's a lot of young kids that are so
destroyed so heartbroken and they don't
know what to do how do I get her back
how do I get her back and I thought you
know what I think I could actually serve
you and here's the thing um if you want
to have a 10 if you want to marry a
queen right because we attract our
complimentary opposites you got to
become the king you gotta be become a
ten right you got to create your own
value you're taking yourself yeah you
got to start there yeah because what you
come clawing back with desperation to
that person that just dumped you you're
still a piece of [ __ ] she left you for a
reason what you got to do is fix you get
into the gym start lifting heavy things
put down the damn phone connect with
people read books right do some
mushrooms go deep inside yourself work
on you you create this kind of value you
take yourself from a six to a seven to a
eight to a nine or ten maybe you do or
don't want this other person but you're
going to attract your complimentary
opposite irrespective of where you are
in your life if you're a piece of [ __ ] I
tell my kids it's all the time the best
it's great advice I'm like Hey guys
you're gonna attract your complimentary
opposite if you work really hard what
you're doing right now and I tell them
all the time you guys are so [ __ ] you
all are so [ __ ] because we have so
much money that you guys never really
you never have to work in your lives you
have to struggle yeah so so if you don't
create your own struggle your own
resistance to forge yourself into this
evolutionary Hunter you you won't have
progress and if you don't have progress
you won't have happiness right so if you
want to be a pizza if you want to
attract a piece of [ __ ] don't do [ __ ]
you're going to attract a piece of [ __ ]
right but if you start working on
yourself if you create if you level up
this is what you're gonna do so I think
that's the best advice you can give
people I believe that I believe that
wholeheartedly and it took me a long
time to kind of arrive at that right you
tend to some people will tend to collect
people
um I don't know why we're trying to fix
them yeah or fix them yeah yeah I mean
like the well I heard somebody say I
think it was Tony Robbins who said uh
you have to become the person you want
to be with and I think that's that's
said that again you have to become the
person you want to be with and I love
that expression I don't understand that
you have to become the person become a
badass to attract the battle yeah you
have to become about it yeah because
once again I think that we're
complimentary opposites yes and I think
that you see people repeating the same
patterns over and over and they can't
figure it out yeah and they get older
and they don't get better sometimes you
get older and you just you get worse
it's not like time it's not like time is
is going to make you a better person
time will just kind of calcify who you
are if you're not making changes right
you've got to keep adjusting your
approach five books you would recommend
fine
I'll give you four carnivore code is my
favorite
Primal fat burner is my second favorite
less than a price is nutrition and
physical degeneration
um I can never ignore the nine ancestral
tenants this is my book this is my ebook
go get it for free boom um the the fifth
book uh probably blame deer secret
revisions oh wow a lot so you're because
Western a price had a huge you know what
that is he was a dentist an orthod
orthodontist basically who started
studying primitive cultures the Inuit
there's the valley in Switzerland he
studied and he found that their teeth
and their facial structures were perfect
they didn't need Invisalign things like
that he said what the [ __ ] is going on
and he was the first guy and it's still
now a science like how nutrition
at an early age and Primal nutrition
affects your facial structure your your
your your your your your teeth your the
Integrity of the enamel and all those
things and then you looked at modern
cultures who had all these tooth decay
people losing their teeth and everything
else and it he was very controversial in
a lot of ways but but boy he's got his
acolytes well there's got to be
something to it like even the way your
facial the way the way your mouth is
structured as you as you're as you're
growing like the kind of calcium you get
and things like that yeah it's really
interesting so you see people like the
Maasai and they have these amazing teeth
strong teeth and once again it is the
nourishment but it's the mechanical
loading and I don't know if he really
identified the mechanical loading but
man you got you get a drumstick chew on
the on the drumstick use your centrals
you know if you're walking around just
go pick up a stick you might look a
little stupid but I'm gonna argue I'm
gonna say you look pretty [ __ ] Primal
chewing on a stick chew on something
hard at first it's not going to feel
real good right but I can I can bite
through Frozen things with my front
teeth and you should be able to so
you're saying to people out there start
with liver let's just make it simple
start with liver and then uh what do
they stay away from sodas sugars [ __ ]
like that you know people aren't going
to do that I just know like and again if
you're not compliant nothing nothing
means anything right so start don't
change anything sleep just start start
with liver start eating liver start
lifting heavy [ __ ] learn the Barbarian
train the barber you'll become a
barbarian and then if you follow my
stories you'll see what I what I advise
every single day start the day by
stacking the sun in the Earth get the
Early Morning Sun On You Through The
Eyes on the face on the skin get the
[ __ ] outside most people don't realize
sleep is the biggest lever but if I say
hey go sleep better let me tell you how
to sleep better you know who's gonna do
it like all these things you got to do
almost nobody right but if you get
outside first thing in the morning that
sets your bio circadian rhythm so your
body knows when to be alert and awake
versus sleepy and sleeping the first Sun
morning exposure is going to set your
bioseircadian Rhythm when you have your
bare feet connected anchored grounded
into the Earth yeah everyone says go
outside as soon as you wake up go
outside beer flip-flops everywhere
that's not Barefoot but yeah thank you
go go do those things they're free
they're accessible takes almost no time
go do those things these are our
ancestor ways to express our high school
you're selling a lot of what you're
saying is it's free a lot of what you're
a lot of the advice you're giving us is
stuff you can do for very little money
and so when I say okay once you start
doing these things I
every single day the stories pour in you
know the 15 year olds that hated their
lives that were embarrassed of the
person that they they were humiliated
you know they couldn't look at
themselves in the mirror and I know that
feeling because I was I was that from 10
to 15. right and so this is why I do
what I do I won't stop this fight right
until this message goes mainstream
because the mess the the stories that
pour in you know the amount of families
that couldn't have kids they couldn't
fulfill the Primal purpose in life not
healthy enough to be fertile enough to
propagate our species and now they start
doing these things liver bone marrow egg
yolks on Earth that's down the damn
phone I mean it's wild how many families
how many lives have been birthed as a
result most of these things are free
they're accessible to everybody I mean
who's bullying you at 15 you're a jack
dude well this is when I came out of the
bullying that's probably why I took a
picture yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean when
I built the armor but there are bullies
bullies uh take on different forms I
mean bullies I mean the whole internet
is a bully well but back then there's no
internet listen I was I was a smallest
kid I mean I went to high school under
five foot tall you know Short came I was
the only white kid at my school you know
um the Rodney King rights were going on
did you grow up in L.A I grew up in San
Antonio it was overwhelmingly Hispanic I
love Sam you know and you know what I
remember when I was growing up like the
only thing I wanted to be was black yeah
that I mean they kicked ass in all the
sports all the girls liked them like my
brother used to cry at night because it
went black
okay because I'm dead serious no I'm
dead serious yeah my brother used to cry
because he wasn't black I was like this
is ridiculous and when I got my ass
handed to me every I mean everyone in my
school like you know they had mustaches
and you know underarm hair and I'm like
none of that [ __ ] for me yeah yeah you
know and I just got used to it and I
didn't have a dad growing up you didn't
and your dad stepped out no he died
before before I had any memory I'm sorry
and so uh I didn't nobody put their arm
around me you know and listen this is
the best thing that ever happened in my
life this is my first real rite of
passage that allowed me to forge the
unrelenting evolutionary Hunter I am so
I was like oh I was a sob story again
you know I'm like I couldn't be more
proud in fact I hope other people need
more resistance more rights of Passage
and this is why you know I I need people
to start learning about the Barbarian
yeah I bet your dad would be proud
though you know what you've become 100
yeah 100 yeah thanks for saying yeah
well you're living you're living this
lifestyle and you've obviously turn it
into a an Empire that's a big [ __ ]
deal so that is again you can say
whatever you want about the liver King
but seems to be working for you and it
sounds like your message is pretty
[ __ ] positive to me because you seem
very passionate about getting young
people healthy because I'm sorry I
travel this country you do too the
majority of our country is not healthy
the majority of our country tries to put
themselves in in a different state by
drinking themselves Numb by drugging
themselves numb antidepressants and
these kinds of things are essentially
everywhere and I don't think we've
figured out health and I don't think we
figured out life I'm reading shantaram
about uh Bombay and he's in the slums of
Calcutta I mean Slims of Bombay and one
thing he said is these people have
they're so poor but he's never counted
more Smiles on the street that's a
[ __ ] significant thing he lived in
this these modern countries and when you
go through when you're in Africa you're
in India there's something about those
those people where you go there's
they're poor as [ __ ] but they're smiling
yeah
there are trappings to Modern Life and I
think that you're I think your rebuttal
to Modern Life is pretty I want you in
here because on the videos you seem like
a positive person and you don't you know
you know how it is like you don't know
if it's an act or whatever it's only get
the vibe I want to feel the vibe you
know as organic as it comes man you're a
good dude we're fans yeah you're a great
person man yeah I'm beyond that the
whole Feast man now Brennan you haven't
[ __ ] eaten enough testicles you got a
tiny piece of liver I was hoping you'd
just buy using that big old testicle I
I'm not gonna do that because I don't my
skin is so nice I don't need I don't
need to shine it up even more that is
that a bull testicle this is bull
testicle right yes yeah good God
well Larry King you're the best brother
that this is one of the best people yeah
your energy everything you're great man
thank you friendly good word real quick
yeah in L.A it's a little different
um you just go around the stores in La
do you go in the stores with your shirt
off what do you go to the stores for
yeah what I mean I mean sure
Primal you know I was talking to an
incredible influencer who really gave me
my first break who's that uh you know
what I'm saying what I'm about to say it
probably doesn't seem very complimentary
not to say his name um but uh he was
wearing this uh earpod thing and it was
uh do you remember Louis Vuitton and I
was like what what is that what is that
thing yeah oh you know I like nice
things and and uh he's like hey don't
you go to stores and stuff and get nice
things and I'm like this is the problem
like why do you think you like nice
things what do you think this says about
you we're conditioned for that it
provides value for me once again it's
like how do you think you're expressing
value and Worth to the world is it
through status signaling with that thing
yeah through your hat or you're treated
differently right if you grow up poor
and you you roll up in a really nice car
with really nice jewelry people treat
you a little bit differently when you're
poor and you're you grow up poor you're
treated with it's humiliating sometimes
so I think some people that that's a
reminder that they never have to face
that humiliation again maybe you know
there's always emotional if you ever
driven a Ferrari liver again not a
Ferrari though yeah no but uh I got one
do you
sf90 uh and then a uh 430. oh wow you
have two of them how come I love cars I
Love Actually I love cars I like the
engineering behind it I like everything
yeah but I I so I have a tank I got a
legit tank an old tank that's it um I
mean the I got an old deuce and a half
military truck the the kind of things oh
we don't have the oh it's about to come
out Justin do you know when the YouTube
video comes out about my ancestral
garage
no that should be pretty soon I I said I
said hey if you can't drive this out
into the middle of my my Ranch I don't
want this in my garage that's funny you
know but but I see these supercars my
kids love my kids do do I yeah I grew up
I guess uh in the living room my dad had
a picture of a 911 Porsche so that was
like the goal so I grew up like oh if I
can afford a Porsche that means I've
done something so as soon as I could
afford a Porsche I got a Porsche okay
called my Downs okay I got a Porsche
yeah hell yeah those are those
Milestones but you also love fashion
some people just like colors and you
should come out of the closet too that's
the other thing
I'm glad you start banging you guys
because he's in the guys well that's
what the caveman did right so I'm gonna
eat liver I'm start [ __ ] dudes as
long as it's not big at all don't turn
your sights on me but yeah I got you you
know the take with this entire show is
you use the such a beta right what do
you mean because I'm wearing my [ __ ]
Invisalign I got five more weeks bro
there's like so many reasons now I can't
take them out because my bite is [ __ ]
up so I gotta wait till it I'm having
trouble you don't need to no you don't
need to you're gonna take it off right
now really yeah you know there's a
functional bike will find itself again
yeah you know again you got to think
Aesthetics or function what's more
important to both the Aesthetics this
[ __ ] guys you know I'll tell you what
that's all [ __ ] the most important
thing is no half measures you pick what
you want it's Aesthetics or function
pick one and if it's Aesthetics that's
fine you know that's fine no I mean
I'm not gonna get better looking as the
years go by so for me I just think the
first time slabbing the [ __ ] face
right now yeah but I'm gonna get my
FaceTime but again you you add in stack
value right it's how strong you are
what's your courage Mastery honor it's
not very strong well well it's your
whole package right because value's not
created equally so it's it's all these
things that you do and at the end of the
day what you express to the outside
world I always tell people like you know
when they're like hey why don't you why
don't you wear a shirt and I'm like why
do you wear a shirt yeah like hey why
don't you go to stores I'm like why do
you go to store I don't know no I
wouldn't wear a shirt either if I do
that well I want my shirt well I mean
this I mean this um you give me 10
minutes with somebody you allow me to
have a conversation I'll burn my [ __ ]
Ferrari right now to do what just to
make you happy
tell me more liver King was trying to
one-up each other let's cut to us
following them around but I just send
you a video of me [ __ ] a dude not a
beta dude you guys talk about that a lot
you realize that I don't even know what
to say yeah no we're basic yeah we're
both closeted but but I would say you
know the way that you love so on beta
and the way that we speak these are
outward expressions of who we are yeah
and what we believe and so um this is my
Primal self right this this is how I was
born my first version undomesticated
self I didn't wear a shirt before social
I don't wear a shirt after starting
social right I don't trim my beard
before social I still don't you know
somebody said hey why do you say liver
King why do you refer to yourself in the
third person right and it's it's because
I got a job to do you know because of
people that are hurting right you got to
remember that my name liver King because
liver is King right so if I can start a
reel and I say liver King here here's
what liver King is having for dinner
never King out yeah this is all part of
my personal brand but it's my truest
most authentic self so you let me have a
conversation with somebody you show me
who they are bare chested this is going
to tell me a lot of what I need to know
about somebody and I'm not looking for a
55 year old that's jacked with an eight
pack right but how you doing things how
you do everything this is why I'm not
surprised that Joe Rogan is ripped to
the Bone looking incredible articulate
as [ __ ] successful beyond measure right
this is why I hold them in the highest
regard I was on a podcast the other day
I said this before I just want to say it
one more time before it gets old there's
four primals I hold in the highest
regard George Washington Chuck Norris
Rocky Balboa well Chuck Norris and then
Joe Rogan that's hilarious number five
is gonna be Brendan Java okay
yeah it's a great list so I say this how
you doing things how you do everything
you know like I'm not surprised when I
meet guys that are that articulate that
successful they're also rep shred and
they look the way that they do because
your physical expression your social
emotional intellectual holistic
expression you know is there's when
there's alignment there
I think you found I would say to people
also that there's you have a reaction to
people it can be positive it can be
negative and I and I think it's
important when you have a I always do
this if I have a negative reaction if I
have it's something about something I go
like this I examine why I'm triggered
and a lot of times I might be triggered
and I think this is for anybody you
might be triggered because that person
might be a reminder of the life you're
not living right that person might be a
reminder of the [ __ ] you're not doing so
sometimes we don't like to be confronted
with real Freedom somebody who's living
their life exactly the way they want to
somebody who's original and rejecting a
lot of the status quo chances they
didn't take that's it it reminds them of
the chances they didn't take and you
know you're on a private jet with your
shirt off eating [ __ ] Raw Liver
nobody knows how to put that in context
they're like [ __ ] you're not allowed
to eat raw it's not good for you then
you're on a [ __ ] private jet
Rich because you're selling fake [ __ ] I
love it okay cool you do it then you
[ __ ] do it I would love to be able to
do that but it doesn't say it seems that
whatever you're doing
you're you're you you're making a lot of
money you have a business you have this
great family you're living exactly the
way where you want to you're raising
good kids and you got abs and nice tits
so let's get and you're walking around
without a shirt on it's it's you know
what it's outrageous I love it you're
you're you're out you're wonderfully
outrageous and I think that's we want to
move to Iran yeah and by the way yeah
listen now I'm grateful and I'm telling
you and your wife's a smoke show we
should also say by the way so you're
you're hidden by the way she's 50.
she's 50. look at that one you look
unbelievable that is unreal I didn't
start eating [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
unbelievable but I mean for real that's
amazing hold on this is insane hold on
that's your biggest accomplishment I'm
sorry wait a minute I'm getting to an
age now and I found somebody in my life
who uh that's your biggest
accomplishment finding the person you're
willing to spend your life with that
when you do that that that is probably
the most I think that's the most
important decision you can make I found
it a while ago though but but this is
what happens people put their best foot
forward to meet one another right then
they get comfortable and then they gain
five pounds or ten pounds they get
married they lose a little bit of weight
they take their pictures they gain five
pounds a year in perpetuity and in five
years you wake up next to a beast yep
maybe you got married and you were both
eights but now you're respective fives
and guess what you might say that you
love the person but how much you want to
bet you don't lust the person that
weighs 350 pounds you don't you don't so
you owe it to yourself and you owe it to
your complimentary opposite to express
your highest most dominant form they
will do the same because they're your
complementary opposite so I I wake up
next to someone that can she's my 10. I
love her and I lost her and and what a
gift this is when you get a wake up to
the person that's your soulmate that you
love and this is the only per nobody
could ever be better people hate 300
people hate you right now wait for that
I'm telling you that I'm telling you
find something wrong everybody did go
like this I don't believe it [ __ ]
this is what we do all of us do it in
one way or another people don't matter
though but yeah I don't Focus I'm saying
I'm saying you have to control yourself
all of us have a a version of that and
until you confront that and until you
embrace the fact that that person might
be an inspiration yeah an example that
you should kind of Point towards then
that you can like harp on the [ __ ]
eats meat no fiber that's not the
[ __ ] that's us but bank that's not
the majority that's not the majority you
want to have a business for those the
majority if you want to be liked it was
the majority this is the deal you don't
want to you don't wanna just you're
controversial you know people are gonna
be mad that's the minority right and the
social media that's the minority exactly
the vulnerable minority that they're
trying to reframe the conversation these
these are the ones making reaction
videos sitting on their couch
confirmation bias and they're attempting
to lead a cancer culture right and if
you're weak you'll allow that to happen
but I'm like listen you want to talk
about that thing I'm going to control my
main bullets that's a side dish and I
try and tell every I give my kids this
advice right when we talk to each other
when you hear Kate when you hear critics
these are just words right that we break
down into syllables the syllables go
through our ear canal innervates with
the brain we assign meaning to it this
is why language is so important this is
why your philosophy and principles are
more important because at the end of the
day whatever somebody said to you
irrespective of the words the syllables
the vibration you assign meaning to it
would I ever assign meaning and say oh
they they hate on me I would never say
that right I would say What's Happening
Here is this person actually hates their
life more than anybody right yeah
they're projecting this this hate back
to the world that's right they're
suffering the most I need to be this is
why I'm here for the world because they
actually need the help so that one you
can be motivated I mean I I don't know
how much that's going to motivate people
to hear that but I think it's important
but but I think when people understand
the ones that matter to them I think
it's funny you can walk around eating
raw meat and get people that worked up
it's [ __ ] great it's it's wild it's
fun as hell we're just getting started
you know we've only been doing this for
a year when did you like this is the
greatest Persona you just decided bucket
I'm gonna I'm gonna start the first time
I saw you you were you were pulling the
sled and you were jacked out of your
mind with your beard and your hair thank
you and eating [ __ ] and then drinking
blood in shot glasses I'm like this
[ __ ] yeah I'm like this is
outrageous yeah enough hey hey and then
I saw you on a private jet and I go I
[ __ ] this
Ryan was triggered I gotta go lift
weights yeah I know I love it I love it
you know somebody told me hey you got to
do this thing on social media and we
always called it anti-social media we
didn't like the way people looked stuck
to their phone and I said I'm never
gonna do that we never had a Facebook
account never had a MySpace we never did
any of that ever and we were proud of
that and then I realized you know what
we do have a vision like we we got to
take this message the ancestral message
mainstream it's too important you know
my why in the world that's people are
suffering my kids were suffering we got
a message to share it's accessible to
everybody we got to do this we have an
obligation to do this and this is what
I'll say about technology and social
media
um technology AKA a utility is a utility
until it no longer is it sounds simple
it's a little bit complex with social
media I only follow nine people half of
my family liver boys and the wife right
and um and I use social for boys yeah I
use social to create and to curate value
when you start to mindlessly consume
content that's a placeholder for
creating the value that come pounds in
the world that allows you to express a
higher form that allows you to attract
that complementary opposite that's a
nine or ten that you wake up to right
and so you got to be really careful
about how you use any technology use it
to create and to curate value for
yourself it's also people living through
their phone just staring at the phones
like you're not living life man there's
literally in a simulation so somebody
said on the on because I made a video
the other day and I said hey why would
you want to play video games when you
can drive these high lifters going
mudding shooting guns and I saw that
yeah okay so somebody responds um must
be nice when you have a million dollars
to do all that stuff and what I'm
thinking I didn't respond right that's
an excuse well this is what I'm thinking
is you know what you you will get the
million dollars if you don't play video
games and go actually produce real life
produce real value right you go do these
things you'll feel like it and so um I I
think the arm was twisted enough when we
had visitors come over and they couldn't
believe the Jaws were dropped they
couldn't believe how we're living and
when you just live the way you live you
don't really know that there's anything
abnormal about it yeah and so enough
people said you gotta get this on on
camera and again wife and I are just
like oh I don't know because we kind of
like our lives right now right but again
if if progress equals happiness we take
on more responsibility that we don't
want to necessarily do right which leads
to progress which leads to more
happiness and this is our fight this is
why we unite this is why we exist today
and again this is why I'm so grateful
for you guys because I desperately need
people to be a successful primals to be
successful like you guys so that I can
have these platforms so that we can
express this message keep finding the
good fight brother it's a phantom yeah
you're always welcome there hell yeah
I'm on board with the whole thing I want
to come out to the ranch me too right
bring some blood let's shoot some stuff
out there and do barbarians yeah I want
to do the Barbarian and I want to eat
some [ __ ] mushrooms and it's the in
your your website is the uh was that
thefitness.com fitness.com is one of my
companies yeah that's where you can get
the whole Feast there's a whole slew of
of supplements on there um that's and
here's the thing like they're all nose
to tail nutrition if you want to learn
more about liver King it's just
liverking.com right um but you know I
just I want people to plug into the
message plug into the stories what
you're going to see is I highlight my
entire day yeah right I wake up out of
my one playing bed I go take a piss on
my favorite tree I'm already stacking
the sun in the earth creating content
creating what what I hope to be valuable
within the first five minutes of my day
right so if you want to plug into
because we talked about a lot of stuff
you're not going to execute Implement
all this stuff but start with lever
because liver is King then tune into the
story stack the Sun and the Earth lift
heavy [ __ ] learn the Barbarian and
you're going to set yourself on a
trajectory to change your life forever
I'm I'm co-signed now I'm [ __ ] pumped
I'm beating liver in Boston this
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm eating
liver doing comedy in Boston this
Thursday Friday Saturday then San Jose
is October 13th through the 15th Salt
Lake City October 20th through 22nd Wise
Guys and then I end October on tour in
Calgary uh it's the rooftop downtown
Calgary and that shows damn near sold
out so we added the show on Friday so
October 27 28 Thumb in Calgary get you
some thick boy.com B I'm in Tacoma this
weekend Tacoma comedy club uh Thursday
through Saturday can't wait uh
Bridgeport Connecticut Stress Factory
October 13 14 15. Schaumburg Illinois
Schaumburg improv October 27 29th I'm in
I'm in Dallas sometime in November I'm
just I'm just saying no or maybe I don't
know where it is yeah somewhere in
November or December I don't know I'll
find out but I'm going to be bugging
because you guys are you how far away
are you from Dallas maybe an hour and a
half or two I saw that you're in Houston
uh but you said you're in Dallas I
didn't see it on there we got to figure
that out I'm in Houston come on man yeah
yeah I could make it over there I'm in
Houston for sure you guys got to come
out to a show we're going to make stuff
happen yeah let's do it brother I'll get
your number and uh we'll make it happen
liver King you're the best man
appreciate it I want to feel the Synergy
man you're a real dude you're a real
good person too man I appreciate you
brother King everybody
whenever we're done so I'm the liver
King so I always gotta end it by saying
what where's the camera which cameras
one of the seven go ahead oh that's your
camera right there so here we go liver
King out yeah yeah